Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
In Südafrika wurde jetzt die nationale KI-Strategie mit KI entworfen.
Da bekommt der Begriff Selbstregulierung eine ganz neue Bedeutung.
Logbuch-Netzpolitik Nummer 553 vom 6. Mai 2026.
Wir sind kurz vor der 555. Also nicht sehr kurz, aber fast.
Fast, ja.
Ja, ist ja auch so eine besondere Zahl.
Ist das eine besondere Zahl?
Ja, das ist dieser Präfix, wo in Amerika immer alle Telefonnummern im Film geschrieben werden.
Das ist der Area Code 555.
Ah.
Den es nicht gibt, damit dann alle nicht zufällig irgendjemand da mit Julia Roberts helfen wollen.
Genau, oder mit, keine Ahnung.
Ich bin auch in dich verliebt.
Ja, ja, genau. Ja, das ist eine interessante Vorsichtsmaßnahme.
Hat man jetzt in Südafrika, aber nicht so gehabt.
Vorsichtsmaßnahmen meinst du?
Ja, also ein bisschen vorher drüber nachdenken, hätte geholfen.
Auf jeden Fall.
Machen wir einfach Agentik jetzt.
Ja, ich kann das ja auch irgendwie verstehen. Es ist ja auch schwierig mit diesem
Jura und den ganzen Paragraphen.
Und auch eine Strategie entwerfen liegt ja jetzt auch nicht so jedem.
Da muss man ja die Dinge aufeinander aufbauen lassen. Das muss irgendwie alles zusammenpassen.
Da muss eine Korrektur lesen.
Da ruft man den Geist. Ja, also dann ist einfach jeder Mitarbeiter im Ministerium
wird mal ganz schnell zum Zauberlehrling.
Ja, und wenn dann der Besen erstmal richtig anfängt zu tanzen,
naja, Walle, Walle, sag ich nur.
Und knapp 10% der akademischen Paper, auf die verwiesen wurde,
gab's nicht. So ist es wieder aufgefallen, ne?
Genau, und das ist so ein bisschen der Klassiker, den wir jetzt immer wieder
sehen. in gewisser Hinsicht die Südafrika ein bisschen spät dran.
Aber das passt wahrscheinlich auch so ein bisschen dazu.
Immerhin haben sie sich darüber Gedanken gemacht, wie man jetzt mit AI mal so umgehen soll.
Und dieses Paper war dann auch schon ganz klug und hat tolle Sachen vorgeschlagen.
Da braucht man eine KI-Kommission, da braucht man einen Ethikrat,
eine Regulierungsbehörde. Gehört auch einfach dazu heutzutage.
Ja.
Aber auch Steuererleichterung, Zuschüsse und Subventionen für die Privatwirtschaft.
Da fragt man sich, ob die da nicht schon in den LLMs was vorgesehen haben,
so nach dem Motto, wenn einer fragt, wir brauchen Geld.
Also ich könnte mir auch vorstellen, dass die,
KI sich gedacht hat, pass auf, wir bauen denen einfach so ein komplett selbstblockierendes
System aus unterschiedlichen Verantwortungsbereichen, die aber überlappen und
gegeneinander aufgestellt sind.
Und dann einfach noch ein bisschen Steuererleichterung dazu,
dann haben wir erstmal zehn Jahre Ruhe und dann ist es eh zu spät.
Also so, ah, ihr wollt uns regulieren, ja, pass auf, dann müsst ihr noch hier
Datenschutzbeauftragten, dann müsst ihr aber noch irgendwie eine Kommission,
dann macht ihr erstmal einen Arbeitskreis, ja.
Dann macht da eine Expertinnenkommission, aber auf Länderebene,
die sich in einem nationalen Normenrat dann nachher einigen müssen und am Ende geht's in den Trilog.
Ja, also man muss ja dem Minister zumindest zugutehalten, dass er dann auch
gleich öffentlich Abbitte geleistet hat.
Schön ist, ich hatte eine Bilderbuch-Entschuldigung vorgelesen.
Ich übernehme die volle Verantwortung, es tut mir sehr leid.
Ja, das ist unter unseren Standards.
Leider nur am Anfang noch vorgelesen, hier eine fein geschliffene Version deines
Entschuldigungsschreiben, in dem ich noch unterwürfiger bin.
Soll ich dir auch noch eine Plakataktion dazu entwerfen? In dem Artikel,
den wir verlinken, wird auch noch auf eine Studie verwiesen von Nature,
die so ganz strategisch mal alle veröffentlichten Papers des letzten Jahres
untersucht haben, um zu gucken, was da noch so alles herbei halluziniert wurde,
also an Referenzen, an diesen Zitaten.
Das ist ja das, woran man das schnell merken kann.
Und waren es 2024 noch 0,3% aller Paper, waren es im letzten Jahr dann schon zweieinhalb Prozent.
Da geht es also mal eben um Faktor 8 hoch, um das mal in absoluten Zahlen auszudrücken.
Das betrifft 110.000 Publikationen.
Ja, das skaliert jetzt einfach mal ordentlich.
Ja, ja, ja, genau. Also Leute, immer Vorsicht mit der Technik.
Da muss man besser nochmal Menschen drüber gucken lassen.
Apropos Mensch, wir hätten noch einen.
Ja, wir begrüßen unsere Rone Kartockel, der es hier im Studio geschafft hat.
Moin, hallo.
Gratuliere.
Wann warst du, ist es einige Zeit her, dass du das letzte Mal hier warst?
Müssen wir dir mal neu vorstellen?
Ja, müssen wir wahrscheinlich. Ich guck mal, wann du schon mal hier vorstellig
geworden bist. Einmal warst du da, stimmt's?
Zweimal.
Zweimal, oh Gott.
Irgendwas mit Daten und Öl.
Ja.
Und ein zweites Mal.
Logbuchnetzpolitik, 492. Ölverschmierte Hände, genau. Das war vor zwei Jahren.
Und kurz vorher hatten wir noch die Bundesverdienst-Coin.
Ah ja.
Logbuchnetzpolitik, 422.
Damit verarsche ich dich hier zu selten. Gut, das ist jetzt nochmal eine Erinnerung.
Ja, genau. So, aber jetzt gab es wieder genug Gründe, dich hier einzufangen.
Deswegen haben wir das gleich mal gemacht.
Du, willst du dich nochmal vorstellen? Hat sich irgendwas geändert an deiner
Vorstellung von der Zukunft?
Hat sich nichts verändert. Ich gucke immer noch an Datenlecks.
Immer noch technisch langweilig, aber spannend, was dahinter ist.
Aber heute geht es nicht um Datenlecks.
Mein anderes Standbein ist sogenannte KI-Überwachung.
Kriegst du da auch Münzen für?
Da kriege ich leider keine Münzen.
Da gibt es Tokens.
Genau, also du fummelst dich, wie man das beim CCC so macht,
ordentlich mal in die Details rein.
Da sprechen wir gleich nochmal drüber. Aber vielleicht sollten wir vorher nochmal
kurz erwähnen, dass alles okay ist.
Ja, also gestern dachten ja wieder viele, das Internet bricht zusammen.
War aber nur ganz kurz so, nur in Deutschland.
Insofern ist es nichts Nichts Besonderes. Internet ist kurz in Deutschland zusammengebrochen,
weil auf einmal ganz viele, tja, Domains nicht mehr erfragt werden konnten.
Viele mögen das als Webseite, konnte nicht erreicht werden deuten,
aber tatsächlich war der Ausfall dieses Mal bei der DE-NIC.
DE-NIC steht für Network Information Center Deutschland, also die Organisation,
die für die Vergabe und den Betrieb der .de-Top-Level-Domäne im Internet zuständig ist.
Also jetzt nicht direkt für Webseiten, sondern eben das Mapping von Domains
auf Adressen und betreibt also dort den Hauptserver quasi.
Also da liegt die Wahrheit, für wem gehört denn jetzt eine bestimmte DE-Domain,
also welcher andere Server darf darüber Auskunft geben und da hat sich dann
wohl jemand etwas verkonfiguriert.
Und einen Fehler gemacht und dieser Fehler führte dazu, dass nicht überall,
aber bei den meisten Anfragen diese als fehlerhaft zurückkamen.
Konkret ist da mit der Verschlüsselung was kaputt gegangen.
Nein.
Wie nein?
Signatur.
Ja, ist ja Verschlüsselung.
Nee. Nein. Nein, das ist nicht Verschlüsselung, das ist Signatur.
Ja, aber die Signatur basiert auf Verschlüsselung. Also worum es geht ist,
es gibt ein Verfahren, das heißt DNSSEC, also die sichere, die secure Variante
von DNS, die verhindern soll,
dass eben falsche Auskunft gegeben wird.
Dass sich da irgendjemand zwischenschiebt und falsche Adressen rausgibt und
das ist ein Problem, das hat man gesehen, deswegen gibt es das jetzt auch schon
seit 20 Jahren, glaube ich, technisch und wird jetzt auch so seit gut 15 Jahren umgesetzt.
Ich glaube, Dänik hat 2010 damit angefangen.
Ich glaube, das Internet hat 2010 angefangen.
Nein, aber ich weiß es jetzt nicht ganz genau.
Auf den 13 Root-Servern wurde das, wenn ich mich jetzt nicht täusche, 2010 eingeführt.
Ihr einen Resolver betreibt,
also das, was man DNS-Server nennt, bei vielen vielleicht 9999 oder 1111 oder
8888 oder irgendwas anderes.
Oder was auch immer die Telekom euch gibt, um dann nachher irgendwie Webseiten drauf zu blocken.
Ich glaube, bei denen meistens ist es 192, 168, 01.
Oder 178.1, weil Fritzboxen, die sind ja relativ...
Was auch immer, auf jeden Fall wird einem das in der Regel durchgereicht. Hier fragt man danach.
Man betreibt üblicherweise lokale Resolver, die irgendwo anders bei DNS-Servern
anfragen und sagen, sag mal bitte diese Domain.
Und irgendwo im Internet muss ja eine Stelle diejenige sein,
die überhaupt sagen darf, ja, diese DE-Domänen gibt es oder nein,
die gibt es nicht und wenn es die gibt, dann unterschreibe ich das auch.
Und dieses Verfahren der Signatur implementiert DNSSEC.
Und was jetzt der DNIC passiert ist.
Ist das, wenn jetzt Anfragen kamen, neue, jeder einzelne Resolver cached die
natürlich auch für eine Zeit.
Also euer Piehole, was ihr zu Hause betreibt, das fragt halt nur in regelmäßigen
Abständen die Domains vom Upstream-DNS-Server ab.
Üblicherweise cached sie die dann für die Time-to-Live, die TTL,
wenn da steht, Time-to-Live ist 24 Stunden.
Dann wird sie sich diesen Wert für 24 Stunden merken, weil sie davon ausgehen,
dass der sich innerhalb der nächsten 24 Stunden nicht ändert dann wird sie aber
den Request nochmal neu machen,
und üblicherweise wird der ganz oben upstream der Request,
signiert, wenn er wirklich an die DENIC geht, wenn also Google beispielsweise
bei der DENIC sagt, hör mal, lange keiner mehr auf Logbuch Netzpolitik gewesen,
sag mal nochmal.
Auf welcher IP-Adresse diese Domain zeigen soll, dann antwortet ein DENIG-Server mit einer Signatur.
Und das ist dann, diese Signatur ist verifizierbar und damit weiß man,
ja, die DENIG hat wirklich, die haben auch die Rechnung bezahlt.
Und der soll auch wirklich dahin zeigen. Und da hat die DENIG für eine Zeit gestern Nacht,
falsche Signaturen angebracht, die dazu führten, dass die DNS-Resolver gesagt
haben, das ist ja falsch, ungültig, gewinnt nicht, mach mal nicht.
Habe ich das richtig erklärt, Matthias?
Überwiegend. Überwiegend, ist schon mal gut. DNSSEC hat auch einen neuen Resource
Record, heißt das, glaube ich, alles sehr lange her,
mit dem man zeigen kann, dass eine Domain nicht existiert und in einer Signatur
dazu, in diesem NSSEC3-Record, ist was schiefgelaufen.
Und die haben dann quasi, die haben einfach bei allen gesagt, die gibt es gar nicht?
Nee, es wurde dann, die Kette konnte nicht mehr verifiziert werden,
die Signaturkette und deswegen funktionierte nichts mehr, was unter .de liegt,
solange man einen eigenen Resolver hat, der das Ganze auch verifiziert.
Ich habe es gemerkt. Habt ihr es gemerkt?
Also ich habe es ehrlich gesagt nicht ausprobiert.
Ich habe in dem Moment überhaupt nicht mit dem Internet rumgeschickt.
Aber ich kann gucken, ob mein Resolver DNS-Sack aktiviert hat,
da bin ich mir eigentlich relativ sicher.
Visit this Website.
Und wer es temporär deaktiviert hat, kann es ja jetzt wieder aktivieren.
Zum Beispiel Cloudflare. Cloudflare waren das, die gesagt haben, machen wir halt aus.
Genau, Usability war wichtiger.
Ich finde es sogar halbwegs, also da kann man geteilter Meinung zu sein,
ich finde es sogar halbwegs verständlich, wenn man weiß, okay,
die verteilen gerade halt einfach falsche Signaturen.
Eventuell konnten die ja sogar, ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob sie so fit waren,
aber vielleicht konnten sie sogar erkennen, okay, das ist immer dieser Key und
der ist halt nicht mehr gültig, weil die Dänik hat ja auch gesagt,
dass es im Rahmen der Rotation passiert ist.
Das klingt für mich so ein bisschen nach, sie haben entweder den neuen nicht
advertized oder einen falschen advertized oder was auch immer.
Es gab einen falschen, aber ich denke, dass die Dänik da in den nächsten Tagen
auch nochmal etwas mehr Aufklärung betreibt.
Erklärt das doch mal. Erklärt doch mal, was da passiert ist.
Also ich würde sagen, sollte nicht passieren, kann mal passieren.
Am Ende nicht so wild, wird vermutlich dazu führen, dass demnächst mal Systeme
aufgesetzt werden, die das verhindern, dass man das so publiziert.
Nachher ist man ja immer schlauer.
Ja, passiert. Meine Güte. Ein bisschen Internet geklattet.
Ja, die Leute sollen ja auch mal von anderen gucken.
Ja, vor allem um die Uhrzeit. Da könnt ihr mal,
US-amerikanische Webseiten euch angucken.
Für alle, die jetzt mit der DNS-Erklärung nicht so viel anfangen konnten,
habe ich nochmal das wunderschöne Video von der Sendung mit der Maus veröffentlicht,
wo so das Resolving von DNS erklärt wird.
Weißt du, wo die mit den IP-Adressen durch die Gänge laufen und so.
Ist länger her, aber ich kann mich erinnern.
Ganz toll.
Haben sie auch schon eine DNS-Sec-Maus?
Das kommt noch.
Ja, so, Herr Torke, du bist ignoriert worden vom Staat,
habe ich gehört, der mag dich nicht mehr und deswegen bist du jetzt,
weiß ich nicht, bist du jetzt aufgeregt, bist du jetzt irgendwie beleidigt oder
ist alles nur so gekommen, wie du gedacht hast?
Ich bin, genau, ich beklage mich jetzt und ich bin so ein bisschen genervt.
Es geht um eine Gesichtersuchmaschine. Da sind zwei Bekannter.
Es gibt Clearview AI, das war so die erste, die groß und bekannt wurde und dann
gibt es die billige Kopie PimEyes.
PIM-EIS wurde bekannter als Frau Klette in Berlin dann zufällig von Journalisten
gefunden wurde, die dann ja auch festgenommen wurde.
Und diese Gesichtersuchmaschine macht das folgende, die durchforstet das Internet
nach Fotos und alle Gesichter in diesen Fotos landen in einer Datenbank und
werden dort mit ihren Fundstellen verknüpft.
Die biometrischen Daten in diesen Gesichtern werden dann noch herausgezogen
analysiert, sodass man ein Bild bei PimEyes hochladen kann.
Und dann sagt mir die Suchmaschine, wo mein Gesicht oder ein ähnliches Gesicht im Internet auftaucht.
Und das ist natürlich ein krasses Werkzeug, denn ich kann mich damit an eine
Demo stellen, Fotos machen und alle Leute, die irgendwo mit ihrem Namen im Internet
auftauchen, kann ich dann de-anonymisieren.
Das heißt, ja, das ist ein Werkzeug, was relativ gefährlich ist und verhindern
wird, dass man auch künftig noch anonym in der Welt da draußen rumlaufen kann.
Es sei denn, man klebt diese schwarzen Balken ins Gesicht, habe ich gehört.
Oder eine Papiertüte über den Kopf, genau.
Das ist halt, also in seinem Ausmaß ist es halt schon echt irre, ne?
Wenn man dann nur so mal kurz drüber nachdenkt, dann hat das ja,
meine Güte, Gesichtersuchmaschine, ne?
Ich kann ja auch Bilder suchen im Internet, aber wenn du letztendlich überlegst,
dass du als RAF-Terroristin noch nicht mal mehr zum Capoeira-Kurs gehen kannst, ne?
Weil du auf Facebook landest und dann jemand dein Fahndungsplakat in so eine Suchmaschine wirft.
Ja, Frechheit.
Ja, während, was ist übrigens, kürzlich habe ich mir nochmal angeschaut,
wie das die Phantombild-Zeichnung von Daniela Kletter aussah.
Überhaupt nichts mit hier zu tun. Aber so das, in dem Fall, dann glaube ich
schon bei 20 Jahre alte Bild, das hat dann sehr schnell gemappt und das sind
eben die, ja, die Biometrie,
Analysen, die genauso jetzt, weiß nicht, so ein Face-ID oder sonst was macht,
aber eben einfach mal einmal auf den gesamten Gesichterbestand des Internets gemacht.
Und mit Kameraüberwachung kombiniert wird das, also es ist halt wirklich krass.
Also das ist das eine, wenn der Staat das dann plötzlich machen kann.
Aber das andere ist halt, dass PIM als einfach gegen Geld zu haben ist.
Das heißt, jede Privatperson kann plötzlich alle anderen de-anonymisieren, identifizieren.
Da bin ich, okay, ich weiß das aus unseren Gesprächen und auch aus der Folge,
wo wir darüber gesprochen hatten, aber das ist halt, also das ist ja nun wirklich,
also da muss man jetzt keine Expertin sein, um zu verstehen,
dass das ja gar nicht geht, das darf man ja gar nicht, weil du ja Personenprofile
baust, also biometrische Personenprofile erstellst, ohne dass die Leute ihre
Einwilligung gegeben haben.
Genau, also die biometrischen Daten sind besonders schützenswerte Daten,
denn diese Daten kann ich nicht einfach ändern.
Wenn mein Passwort verloren geht, ist das doof, aber ich habe noch andere, ist okay.
Wenn die biometrischen Daten zu meinem Gesicht verloren gehen,
dann sind die Daten weg und es ist dann eher kompliziert, das Gesicht so zu
ändern, dass das auf was anderes hinzeigt.
Insofern ist die Eingriffstiefe enorm und die Datenschutzgrundverordnung sagt ganz explizit,
biometrische Daten sind besonders schützenswerte Daten und ohne explizite Einwilligung
darf ein Unternehmen wie PIMEIS überhaupt nichts damit tun. Das interessiert sie nur nicht.
Ursprünglich war PIMEIS in Polen ansässig. Dann haben die plötzlich von der
DSGVO gehört, sind die auf die Seychellen umgezogen, dann später noch nach Belizeh.
Heute sind sie angeblich oder tatsächlich in Dubai und machen weiter.
Sie klappern das Internet fortwährend nach Gesichtern ab.
Das fand ich nicht so schön.
Die haben mich nicht gefragt. Ich habe meine Einwilligung nicht erteilt.
Deswegen habe ich mich bei der Hamburger Datenschutzbehörde darüber beschwert.
Das war ungefähr Mitte 2020.
Ich habe halt gesagt, erstens, PymEyes hat mir nicht sagen wollen,
welche Daten sie über mich haben.
Ich hatte also zuerst ein Auskunftsersuchen gestellt an PymEyes und wollte wissen,
was sie über mich wissen.
Und zusätzlich war dann aber auch klar, dass sie mein Gesicht im Internet gefunden
und verarbeitet haben, das Ganze ohne meine Einwilligung und ich hätte gerne gehabt,
dass die Hamburger Behörde darauf hinwirkt,
dieses kriminelle Unternehmen PIMEIS in seiner Arbeit zu beschränken.
Also du hast dich wahrscheinlich da angemeldet, hast ein Bild von dir reingeladen
und hast dann eine DSGVO-Auskunft gestellt, was du ja wahrscheinlich einfach darfst. Also was ein...
Rechtsanspruch ist, den du gegenüber jedem europäischen Unternehmen hast.
Und dann hast du wahrscheinlich gesagt, jetzt löscht mich bitte da raus.
Genau, also nicht nur gegenüber jedem europäischen Unternehmen,
sondern auch jedem Unternehmen, was irgendwie in Europa tätig ist oder hier
ein Büro hat und so weiter. Aber genau.
Und haben die überhaupt geantwortet?
PimEyes hat nicht geantwortet, beziehungsweise hat geantwortet,
ich soll irgendwie meinen Ausweis, glaube ich, noch irgendwo hinladen oder so.
Aber auch das mache ich nicht.
Schicken Sie uns mal Ihren biometrischen Ausweis, bitte. Vor der Unterrückseite.
Genau. In dem Verfahren hatte ich und habe ich dankenswerterweise Unterstützung
von Neub, dem österreichischen Verein rund um Max Schrems.
Die haben mich auch in dem Verfahren gegen die Gesichtersuchmaschine Clearview AI begleitet.
Das heißt, wir kannten uns und die haben das und das tun sie bis heute rechtlich
begleitet, weil ich da halt nach wie vor Laie bin.
Und so ging das dann einige Jahre hin und her. Wir haben immer mal wieder nachgefragt,
liebe Datenschutzbehörde, wie sieht es denn aus?
Könnt ihr da was machen? Wollt ihr was machen? dann ist oft über längere Strecken
nichts passiert, bis wir mal wieder nachgefragt haben.
Aber so richtig passiert ist am Ende nichts.
Wir mussten darauf hinwirken, dass wir einen Bescheid bekommen,
also dass die Behörde formal das Verfahren zu meiner Beschwerde mit irgendeinem Ergebnis einstellt.
Und das hat die Behörde dann tatsächlich auch getan.
Die hat mein Beschwerdeverfahren einfach eingestellt nach mehr als fünf Jahren.
Mit Begründung?
Mit Begründung. Ohne ein nennenswertes Ergebnis.
Und zwar haben sie letztendlich gesagt, wir stellen das Verfahren ein,
weil wir glauben, dass wir PIM-Eis nicht erreichen können.
Können die nicht einfach die Eigentümer über PIM-Eis suchen oder so?
Sie glauben, dass sie zum Zeitpunkt deiner Beschwerde war ja wahrscheinlich
schon relativ einfach, die zu erreichen.
Ja, da war noch bekannt, wo sie in Polen sitzen, aber die Behörde ist da nie vorbeigegangen.
Es war auch nicht so einfach mit der polnischen Behörde, die da mit zuständig
ist, zusammenzuarbeiten. So, das gehört dazu.
Also es ist sicherlich nicht der einfachste Fall, aber es ist auf jeden Fall
ein spannender Fall, weil es halt im Prinzip alle Menschen in Europa,
die irgendwo ein Bild im Netz haben, berührt.
Diese Gesichtersuchmaschinen spielen ja jetzt auch gerade im Sicherheitspaket eine größere Rolle,
wo diese in meiner Wahrnehmung offensichtlich illegalen Unternehmen die Nutzung.
Derer Dienstleistungen für Strafverfolgungsbehörden legalisiert werden sollen.
Über Umwege, genau. Also zuerst einmal behaupten öffentliche Stellen,
dass sie das im Zweifel auch selbst können, ohne eine Biometriedatenbank anzulegen,
denn das dürften sie nicht.
Aber man kann so eine Gesichtersuchmaschine nicht bauen, ohne eine Biometriedatenbank
aufzubauen. Ansonsten müsste man, wenn ich nach einem Bild in dieser Suchmaschine
suche, in Echtzeit das ganze Internet durchforsten.
Das funktioniert natürlich nicht so. Dazu ist das Internet zu groß.
Und vor diesem Hintergrund geht das nur, wenn man eine Datenbank aufbaut.
Die Behörden dürfen das nicht. Aber in dem Gesetzesvorschlag wollen die sich
dann die Hintertür offen halten, einfach auf den Dienstleister zuzugreifen,
der das netterweise schon erledigt hat.
Was glaubst du, wird jetzt passieren? Also die Hamburger Datenschutzbehörde
wegen Untätigkeit verklagen, was wird jetzt das Ergebnis sein?
Oder sagt dann jetzt eine Richterin, ihr müsst was machen, versucht die anzurufen? oder so?
Wir haben mehrere Optionen auch vorgeschlagen in der Klage, die ich jetzt nicht
alle hier ausführen möchte.
Klar ist, auch als europäischer Bürger kann ich heute bei PIM als Euro einwerfen, um Account zu kriegen.
Das heißt, irgendwo werden die auch ein Konto haben, wo sie Geld aus der EU,
entgegennehmen können.
Das heißt, es gäbe mit Sicherheit auch ein Konto, auf das die Datenschutzbehörde
vielleicht zugreifen kann, wenn sie denn eine Strafe gegen PIM-Eyes verhängen würde.
Und dass das geht, die Frage stellt sich nicht. Zum einen sagt die Behörde selbst,
das, was PIM-Eyes tut, ist klar illegal.
Zum anderen gibt es diese andere Gesichtersuchmaschine Clearview AI.
Und da haben diverse Behörden, wieder keine deutsche, hohe Millionenstrafen
gegen Clearview AI verhängt.
Das heißt, die haben sich nicht davon abhalten lassen, dass es vielleicht schwer
ist, auch das Geld einzutreiben, sondern erst einmal geht es darum,
diese Strafe zu verhängen und danach kümmert man sich darum, das Geld einzutreiben.
Aber man kann ja nicht einfach darauf verzichten, eine Strafe zu verhängen,
weil man glaubt, dass man die nicht durchsetzen kann.
Gegen Clearview AI gibt es, okay du hast gesagt, nicht von deutschen Behörden,
also nicht vor deutschen Gerichten.
Genau, also im Kontext Clivio AI haben unter anderem die Behörden in Frankreich,
Italien, UK 20 Millionen Euro Strafen gegen Clivio AI verhängt.
Betreibt Clearview AI sein Dienstangebot weiterhin?
Haben die in irgendeiner Weise auf die Strafen reagiert im Sinne von,
ah ja, okay, habt ihr recht, war kacke, hier sind eure 20 Mio und jetzt machen
wir hier so ein Opt-out-Button an jedes Gesicht?
Die haben auch nicht reagiert, aber die sind auch nicht im europäischen Markt tätig.
Das heißt, die entziehen sich dem Zugriff, während PIMEIS ja weiterhin in der EU tätig ist.
Und man könnte dann auch gucken, was tun denn die Geschäftsführer?
Sind die vielleicht irgendwie persönlich haftbar?
Die könnte man ja vielleicht zum Beispiel mittels biometrischer Passkontrollen
an unseren Flughäfen fangen dann.
Das wäre eine Maßnahme. Genau, also jedenfalls gefällt uns nicht,
dass die Hamburger Behörde da mit uns fünf Jahre lang an dem Fall dran war und
dann ohne Ergebnis das Ganze eingestellt hat.
Also das geht einfach nicht, schon gar nicht in so einem krassen Fall,
der halt die Anonymität in der Welt da draußen bedroht.
Und insofern hoffen wir sehr, dass das Gericht zu der Einschätzung kommt,
dass die Behörde was tun muss und die Behörde im Anschluss dann auch tatsächlich etwas tut.
Glaubst du dahinter, also wie viel vermutest du dahinter, dass eventuell irgendwelche
Polizeibehörden sagen, Mensch, lass das ruhig illegal sein, aber ist halt schon spannend?
Das ist keine Vermutung. Das hessische LKA hat PIMEIS in zwei Jahren 2021, 2022 getestet.
Das haben sie nie an die große Glocke gehängt.
Und der hessische Datenschutzbeauftragte hat das irgendwann erfahren und hat
dann die Weiternutzung untersagt.
Das heißt, die Polizei ist da ganz offen.
Hessen, haben die das im Rahmen ihrer Videoüberwachung gemacht?
Oder ist das noch in Anführungszeichen, wahrscheinlich ist das nicht getrennt,
aber zumindest keine Live-Gesichtserkennung.
Aber die haben ja, wenn ich mich nicht täusche, KI-Videoüberwachungssysteme
zum Beispiel am Frankfurter Hauptbahnhof.
Habe ich das richtig in Erinnerung?
Das hast du richtig in Erinnerung, aber das sind zwei auch zeitlich getrennte Dinge.
Ist das, wie oft wird ein Datenschutzbeauftragter von datenschutzorientierten verklagt?
Ich glaube, das kommt immer mal wieder vor. Für Hamburg ist es vielleicht eine
Premiere, das weiß ich nicht.
Ich finde es auf jeden Fall spannend.
Das ist auch witzig, weil die wahrscheinlich so denken, ach ja,
hier wieder ein gelber Umschlag vom Gericht, wen haben wir denn da verklagt?
Ah ne, wir werden verklagt.
Tja, die können es auch keinem recht machen, ne? Auf beiden Seiten nur Prügel.
Ja, wenn man die Behörde halt sitzt rum, macht nichts, kriegt halt irgendwann
Ärger. Aber dafür kriegst du Pension.
Ja, wenn sie was machen, kriegt sie ja auch Ärger.
Von wem? Von mir nicht. Wenn die dieses PIM 1 zumachen würden, würde ich sagen...
Naja, die jetzt vielleicht nicht, aber wir hatten das ja schon hier mit den Finanzbehörden.
Die haben doch auch nichts gemacht.
Ja, wenn die Steuerhinterzieher verfolgen sollen. Und dann tun sie auch noch
was in dem Bereich, dann wird sofort gekürzt.
Ja, genau. Stimmt, da müssen die Leute in die NGOs flüchten.
Vielleicht reift die Erkenntnis, dass es in unseren Fällen leichter ist,
was zu tun, weil wir nicht einfach aufhören, sondern auch nach fünf Jahren ein
Interesse daran haben, was passiert.
Genau, wir machen nämlich dann auch Podcast drüber. Das habt ihr jetzt davon.
Mit biometrischer Stimmerkennung.
Ja, genau.
Die, um dem Ganzen mal einen größeren, also dieses Thema, KI,
Videoüberwachung, Gesichtserkennung, diese Biometriedatenbanken,
die sind ja ohne, also wenn es...
Meine technische Vorstellung ist, die kannst du relativ einfach,
wenn du sie einmal hast, auch mit entsprechender Rechenpower an ein Videosystem
dranhängen und da Live-Erkennung drin machen.
Das braucht gar nicht so viel Rechenpower.
Okay, sorry.
Demonstrationen, Fußball, du hattest auch eine schöne, dein Vortrag war im Millerton, ne?
Genau, ich habe einen Vortrag gehalten mit der braun-weißen Hilfe zusammen.
Ich bin ja Melanthon-Hörer. Auf einmal höre ich da kein Torkel.
Aber das war eine Aufzeichnung einer Veranstaltung, die du vor Ort im Melanthor gemacht hast.
Richtig?
Genau.
Im Melanthor.
Du bist auch Melanthon-Podcast-Hörer.
Ich höre Melanthon-Podcast.
Hast du mich auch schon mal einen Melanthonen-Podcast.
Nee, dann mach ich mal aus. Dich hör ich schon ab und zu beim Textilvergehen dann.
Den Link müssen wir noch raussuchen mit der,
Folge.
Genau. Und da ging es unter anderem oder schwerpunktmäßig um KI-Überwachung im Kontext Fußball.
Da passieren ja auch spannende Dinge. Also wenn sich in einem Stadion mit 40.000
Menschen, drei falsch verhalten, weil sie vielleicht Pyro zünden,
da muss man gleich alle erkennen und überwachen.
Gesichtserkennung ist ein großes Thema, ist Stand heute auch illegal.
In Spanien haben sie das mal ausprobiert in der Liga. Die spanische Datenschutzbehörde
hat dann ordentliche Geldbußen verhängt.
Glaubst du, wenn wir jetzt von der, also ich meine, dass der Hamburger Datenschutzbeauftragte
dem Spuk ein Ende bereitet,
die Hoffnung war ja wahrscheinlich eh gering, aber es ist natürlich gleichermaßen
ein verheerendes Signal,
dass noch nicht einmal der Hamburger Datenschutzbeauftragte zum Schütze eines
Bürgers der Hansestadt tätig wird, um sein Gesicht zu schützen.
Also ich habe die Chance nicht so gering eingeschätzt. Der hamburgische Datenschutzbeauftragte bzw.
Der Vorgänger im Amt hat sich ja schon sehr für KI-Überwachung auch interessiert.
Ein paar Jahre her im Rahmen von G20 hat die Hamburger Polizei mit Gesichtserkennung
experimentiert. Und das fand der damalige Datenschützer nicht so lustig und
die haben eine Löschung dieser Biometriedatenbank der Polizei angeordnet.
Die Polizei unter Andi Grote hat das ignoriert und die haben dann länger vor Gericht gestritten.
Das war der mit dem Pimmel, ne?
Ja, warum ist der eigentlich so eins Pimmel?
Genau.
Das ist auch ungeklärt die Frage, oder?
Also das heißt, grundsätzlich ist da auf jeden Fall schon Interesse bei den
Behörden da. Ich vermisse nur mehr Engagement.
Momentan passiert ja auch an anderen Ecken viel mit Gesichtserkennung.
Also in verschiedenen Städten, vor allem im öffentlichen Personennahverkehr
wird auch mit Verhaltenserkennung experimentiert.
Und oft genug, so scheint es mir zumindest, erfahren auch die Datenschutzbehörden
erst aus der Presse oder aus dem Parlament davon, dass gerade was passiert.
Lange war zum Beispiel nicht wirklich bekannt, dass die Hamburger Hochbahn an
zwei U-Bahn-Haltestellen Verhalten bewertet.
Irgendwann kam raus, dass die Bremer Straßenbahn auch schon über ein Jahr lang
mit diesen Verhaltensüberwachungen experimentiert und und und.
Der erste größer diskutierte Feldversuch war dann dieses Südkreuz-Ding noch, gab es davor schon was?
Davor gab es schon mal was, aber der erste große mit auch sehr schön kreativen
Protest war in Berlin-Südkreuz, genau.
Und das Schöne dort war etwas, was wir auch ganz häufig danach noch beobachtet haben.
Berlin-Südkreuz hat die Polizei sich selbst evaluiert.
Das heißt, die haben da Gesichtserkennung ausprobiert und hinterher hat die
Polizei raufgeschaut und festgestellt, das war alles super, das brauchen wir.
Und das haben wir bei folgenden Experimenten, zum Beispiel zur Verhaltensüberwachung
in Mannheim oder auch in Hamburg, ebenso festgestellt.
Da hat die Polizei sich wieder selbst evaluiert und alles ging auf grün, alles funktioniert.
Dummerweise ist der Pilot in Mannheim nach fünf Jahren noch nicht fertig gewesen.
Deswegen haben sie das Pilotprojekt, das so wunderbar funktioniert,
nochmal um drei Jahre verlängert.
Also das funktioniert hinten und vorne nicht, aber die Polizei ist immer begeistert.
Also das scheint echt ein Erfolgsmodell zu sein. Also KI reguliert sich selber,
Polizei kontrolliert sich selber und dann machen wir jetzt noch die PISA-Studie,
da evaluieren sich die Schülerinnen und Schüler einfach in Zukunft selber und
dann geht es in diesem Land endlich wieder bergauf.
Oder? Also so stelle ich mir das vor. War das nicht auch so,
dass beim Südkruz dann, war das überfragt den Staat oder da sind wir doch irgendwann
noch an die Studien und die wirklichen Zahlen gekommen, die dann irgendwie so katastrophal waren?
Irgendwie so mit 70 Prozent richtig und denkst so, äh.
Aber auch nur nachdem man das massiv geschönt hat, indem man die drei getesteten
Systeme miteinander verbindet, was in der Praxis ja niemand machen würde.
Und selbst dann käme man auf mehrere hundert verdächtige Personen pro Tag nur am Bahnhof Südkreuz.
Was jetzt ja so unrealistisch ist.
Also warst du da schon mal? Hast du da mal einen Tag rumgestanden?
Also da kommen die ja alle ziemlich verdächtig vor.
Vor allem diese Typen mit der Bank hat Hunde, hat die da irgendwie...
Dieser Kontext Videoüberwachung, wir reden jetzt von Bahnhöfen,
in Berlin hat die CDU, die ja jetzt sogar auch diesen Stadtstaat regiert,
sogar mit intelligente Videoüberwachung, das haben die auf Plakate geschrieben, das war eine, die Idee,
so chinesische Videoüberwachungssysteme auszurollen, war etwas...
Wovon die sich Wählerinnenstimmen versprochen haben.
Aber nicht beim Abgeordnetenhaus, das haben sie wieder rausgenommen. Das war denen zu heiß.
Also die wollten unter anderem beim Görli und bei anderen Plätzen überwachen,
dann bei politisch heiklen oder interessanten Orten, irgendwie Rotes Rathaus, Abgeordnetenhaus,
Innenbehörde oder so und das Abgeordnetenhaus haben sie wieder rausgenommen.
Dabei ist da, wer das für ist.
Kriminelle hier?
Wahrscheinlich schlägt das System dann die ganze Zeit an.
Drogen hier im Abgeordneten? Nein, da müsst ihr im Girlie gucken.
Wie lange ist das her, wo sie mal irgendwie den Koksanteil im Abwasser vom Bundestag
irgendwie nachgemessen haben? Das ist auch schon eine alte Geschichte.
War auf jeden Fall signifikant.
Naja, auf jeden Fall, was ich mich in diesem Fall ja, ich meine,
bei Gesichtserkennung ist es ja so, die stimmt oder die stimmt nicht.
Also entweder du hast die richtige Person oder nicht.
Das ist ja in gewisser Hinsicht noch eine relativ klar zu entscheidende Geschichte.
Kannst natürlich voll positives haben, aber man kann es auf jeden Fall klar überprüfen.
Aber dieses ganze verdächtiges Verhalten, ich meine, da hat ja immer jeder eine
ganz andere Auffassung davon, was das ist.
Unter Umständen auch komplett entgegengesetzte Definitionen.
Mein Verhalten wird sicherlich von manchen als verdächtig angesehen und wenn
ich mir deren Verhalten anschaue, ist es wahrscheinlich auch schon verdächtig,
weil es genau anders ist als mein Verhalten.
Und die Betreiber sind da auch nicht klar, welches Verhalten jetzt verdächtig ist.
Genau, wie ist das überhaupt definiert?
Sind es Prügeleien oder ist eine Menschenansammlung schon gefährlich oder eine
Person, die rumlungert, nicht arbeitet?
Also das wahrscheinlich auf jeden Fall. Ja, das ist ein wirkliches Problem und
das finde ich auch in dieser ganzen Debatte am absurdesten, dass sowas nicht
als erstes hinterfragt wird.
Ja, es gibt noch einen Punkt, der oft hinten runterfällt und zwar stimmt es,
sag ich mal, dass man leicht überprüfen kann, hat das Gesichtserkennungssystem
jetzt hier richtig entschieden oder nicht.
Das Problem ist aber so eine Technikgläubigkeit, die immer entsteht,
wenn wir einen Computer benutzen.
Und wenn ich einen Computer nutze und der Computer sagt so, das ist wirklich
Linus Neumann und der ist gesucht, dann glaube ich dem System,
weil das System das ja sagt und das System niemals Unrecht hat.
Und vor diesem Hintergrund sind diese Systeme nochmal gefährlicher,
weil einfach nicht hinterfragt wird, welches Ergebnis da kommt.
Das heißt, auch dieser Faktor, dass das System vielleicht mal daneben liegt
und die Polizei dann sagt, das wird eh alles nochmal manuell überprüft,
hilft nur bedingt, weil die Polizistinnen und Polizisten, die das überprüfen,
die haben halt diese Technikgläubigkeit und schauen da vielleicht gar nicht so genau hin.
Und es gibt genug Beispiele auf der ganzen Welt, wo halt Leute per Gesichtserkennung
vermeintlich identifiziert gefunden wurden und dann ein paar Tage zu Unrecht hinter Gittern saßen.
Es gibt, ich denke, das muss man aber auch noch kombinieren mit,
so aktuell diskutieren wir einzelne Orte im Probebetrieb.
Hansaplatz ist das in Hamburg?
Genau.
Dann die Bahnhöfe spielen häufig eine Rolle.
Nur in Einzelfällen bisher.
Aber genau, also diese Technologie, wenn sie dann einmal ausgerollt ist,
früher, früher in der guten alten Zeit, ihr erinnert euch, wenn du da eine Videoüberwachung
hattest, dann lief die irgendwie so mit. Es konnte sich eigentlich auch niemand anschauen.
Viele Überwachungsvideos haben einfach so ein Rolling-Ding. Die nehmen die letzten
zehn Tage, wenn dann was ist, Wenn irgendwo eine Strafanzeige eingeht oder so,
dann werden diese Videos eingeschaut.
Trotzdem wird natürlich alles aufgezeichnet, aber es wird nicht...
Alles auch in Echtzeit analysiert und jetzt hast du Systeme,
du hast gerade gesagt, der rechnerische Aufwand oder der Rechenaufwand hält
sich sogar in überschaubaren Mengen,
wo du sagen kannst, alles klar, wir stellen hier von mir 50 Kameras auf und
wir lassen dann eine KI drüber laufen und fertig ist.
Da braucht man nicht mal mehr einen Menschen, der sich das alles anschaut und
du kannst wirklich eben eine große Anzahl Kameras, also einen kompletten Raum,
einen kompletten öffentlichen Raum,
in Großbritannien stehen ja in vielen Bereichen und Städten schon lückenlose
Kameraüberwachung bereit und du kannst jetzt die volle Auswertung vollautomatisch machen.
Und dann würde sich ja zum Beispiel so eine Frage stellen, ah okay,
jetzt haben wir gerade erkannt, dass der Kantorkel da gerade mal wieder die
letzte Bahn nach Hamburg nimmt.
Wenn wir uns jetzt schon die Mühe gemacht haben, das Gesicht zu erkennen,
können wir doch auch eben loggen, dass er jetzt zu dem Zeitpunkt da war.
Machen wir doch bei einer Webseite auch nicht anders. Und wer will denn das?
Wir wollen doch, dass das Internet so schön ist wie unsere reale Welt.
Also dieser ökonomische Skalierungsfaktor in der Massenüberwachung,
den stelle ich mir da auch ziemlich irre vor.
Du forderst eine Vorratsdatenspeicherung für den öffentlichen Raum.
Ich fordere es, sie zu verhindern.
Ja, das werden wir auf jeden Fall dann auch irgendwann bekommen.
Aber wir sind uns ja einig, der öffentliche Raum darf ja kein rechtsfreier Raum sein.
Und deswegen verklagen wir den Hamburgs-Bahn-Schutz-Bahn-Utrag.
Da aber schließt sich der Kreis.
Alright. So, was haben wir noch?
Ein absurdes Gesetz soll kommen.
Da gab es jetzt einen Kabinettsbeschluss. Und zwar sieht das Bundesverkehrsministerium
die Chance, 1,1 Millionen Wartestunden einzusparen.
Außerdem soll ein bisschen Personal gespart werden.
Hast du also mal ausgerechnet, wie viele Stunden ihr jetzt auf den Hamburger
Datenschutzbeauftragten gewartet habt, von diesen 1,1 Millionen?
Zwei, drei, ja.
Und zwar soll der Check-In-Vorgang,
entbürokratisiert werden. Jedenfalls läuft das unter dem Stichwort Bürokratieabbau,
und jeder Fluggast soll künftig eine Minute beim Check-In Das heißt,
statt zwei Stunden vorher müssen wir künftig nur noch eine Stunde 59 am Flughafen sein.
Und was genau haben Sie da vor?
Momentan muss man ja an verschiedenen Stellen beim Flughafen Reisepass und oder Bordkarte vorzeigen.
Und das soll durch Entbürokratisierung alles künftig per Gesichtserkennung laufen,
sodass man einmal kontrolliert wird und dann an den fortlaufenden Stationen
per Gesichtserkennung wiedererkannt wird.
Das ist der Plan.
Ich glaube, ein ähnliches System habe ich tatsächlich schon in anderen Ländern gesehen,
wo im Prinzip die Immigration so ist, dass da so Terminals sind,
wo du deinen Pass rein, also das, was du von der Passkontrolle kennst,
dass du Biometriepass draufhalten, automatische Abgleich,
das Gate geht auf und wenn es ein Problem gibt, sitzen dahinter noch zwei, drei,
Grenzschützer in so einem Kabuff und warten, dass sie irgendwie einen fangen.
In dem Fall, dass du dann quasi so eine interne ID und mit deinem aktuellen Gesicht durch...
Zoll, Gate und Immigration-Gest, meine ich auf anderen Kontinenten schon gesehen
zu haben. Geht es um sowas?
Genau, es geht um sowas und eben nicht nur um die Einreise ins Land,
also nicht nur um die hoheitliche Aufgabe, denn unsere Reisepässe sind ja alle
mal biometrisiert worden, um Terroristen zu fangen.
Sondern es geht jetzt auch darum, dass Fluggesellschaften Zugriff auf diese Daten kriegen.
Der Gesetzgeber möchte erreichen, dass das Flughafenerlebnis Ende zu Ende mit
weniger Kontrollen vonstatten geht.
Das soll natürlich Personal einsparen, aber eben auch eine Minute pro Person, die reisen möchte.
Und dabei gibt es eine ganze Menge Probleme. Zum einen haben wir diese biometrischen
Daten, die für andere Zwecke erhoben wurden.
Dann wird gesagt, dieses System ist freiwillig nutzbar. Wer es nicht nutzen
möchte, dem entstehen keine Nachteile.
Eine Minute meines Lebens. Länger in der Lounge.
Nicht nur das, sondern es gibt ja auch diese Nacktscanner, Körperscanner,
die auch freiwillig sind.
Und immer wenn ich sage, ich möchte hier freiwillig nicht durchgehen,
gewinne ich die Spezialbehandlung.
Und dann wird mein Laptop auch nochmal auf Sprengstoff untersucht.
Also am Flughafen gibt es einen relativ hohen sozialen Druck,
die technischen Systeme, die da sind, auch zu nutzen.
Ansonsten verpasse ich meinen Flieger oder werde intensiver durchleuchtet und
nur ich als gar nicht so alter weißer Mann kann mir das erlauben,
da gelegentlich zu sagen,
ich möchte die Spezialbehandlung und insbesondere Leute mit einem anderen Verhältnis
zu Polizei werden sich dem beugen müssen, um einfach nicht aufzufallen.
Und dazu kommt dann, dass das ganze Gesetz mit Bürokratieabbau beworben wird.
Also man möchte pro Person eine Minute sparen, man möchte 60 Millionen im Jahr sparen.
In Wahrheit schafft man da zusätzlichen Aufwand. Denn heute habe ich vielleicht
mein Bordticket ausgedruckt dabei, vielleicht habe ich es auf dem Handy,
das zeige ich vor, gehe durch, fertig, die Infrastruktur ist da.
Künftig brauche ich eine Infrastruktur, wo mein Gesicht an verschiedenen Stellen
im Flughafen erkannt wird, dann müssen diese Daten hoffentlich sicher irgendwo verarbeitet werden,
dann hoffentlich auch nach kurzer Zeit wieder gelöscht werden und das Ganze
dann auch noch sicher miteinander abgeglichen werden.
Gleichzeitig brauche ich immer noch Backup-Prozesse, denn diese biometrischen
Verfahren machen Fehler.
Die Chips in Reisepässen können genauso gut kaputt sein und am Ende schaffe
ich da einfach ein Monster von technischer Infrastruktur, während es heute reicht,
einen QR-Code meiner Bordkarte vorzuzeigen.
Nein, nein, nein. Das kann überhaupt nicht sein. Ich habe ja mal in dem Entwurf nachgeschaut.
Hier Entwurf eines Gesetzes zur Ermöglichung der digitalen Fluggastabfertigung.
Da steht hier ganz klar drin, für die Wirtschaft verringern sich die Bürokratiekosten
um 62,995 Millionen Euro jährlich.
Ja, die Bürokratiekosten vielleicht, aber dieses Gesichtserkennungssystem.
Es entsteht ein einmaliger Erfüllungsaufwand in Höhe von 884.000 Euro.
Das heißt, das Gesetz zu machen oder was?
Erfüllungsaufwand für die Wirtschaft heißt das Kapitel. Und für die Verwaltung
ergibt sich keine Änderung.
Weitere Kosten keine.
Ich hab mich ja ab und zu mal im beruflichen Kontext auch mit Flugsicherheitssystemen
und diesen Check-in-Systemen auseinandergesetzt.
Es ist zumindest so,
Das ist, also einigen von euch ist sicherlich noch bekannt, dass es diese Amadeus-Codes
gibt, die jede einzelne Reise hat so einen achtstelligen,
scheinbar zufälligen Code, der deine eine eindeutige Reise für den Zeitraum
von 90 Tagen ist, weil man mehr als 90 Tage oder 60 Tage daran nicht mehr abbilden
kann in den Flugbewegungen.
Und ich habe mich immer sehr gewundert, warum eigentlich die Fluggesellschaften
überhaupt noch auf dieses System setzen, weil das ja so beknackt ist.
Und auch einige, also der Bereich ist zum Beispiel enumerierbar,
gab es auch vor einigen Jahren schon Kongressvorträge darüber und so weiter und so fort.
Und der Grund, warum das so ist, ist, weil es eben der weltweite Standard ist.
Also wenn die, eine Fluggesellschaft muss üblicherweise viele Flughäfen auf
dem Globus anfliegen und in jedem dieser Flughäfen möchte sie natürlich auch,
dass ihre Tickets zum Beispiel dazu geeignet sind,
Zugang zu diesem Flughafen zu erlangen.
Ja, dass jetzt nicht jeder Flughafen so ein unterschiedliches Pritix hat oder so.
Ah, nee, wir haben hier Eventim, wenn du hier rein willst. Achso,
du hast ein QR-Code von Delta Airlines.
Ja, nee, da musst du zu dem anderen Scanner gehen. Das heißt,
die haben ein weltweit einheitliches Zugangssystem zu Flughäfen.
Und allein daran finde ich es schon halt amüsant, dass Deutschland sich jetzt
ausgerechnet einbildet.
Ja, pass auf, da können wir eine Minute rausschneiden, kostet 800.000 und spart
60 Millionen im Jahr für die Wirtschaft, dass wir da jetzt mehr oder weniger
Sonderlocken stricken, die dann am Ende...
Zwischen Airlines und Flughäfen ausgehandelt werden. Weil die eine Sache,
die ich mir sehr schwer vorstellen kann, ist, dass irgendeine internationale
Airline, weil jetzt Deutschland sagt, pass auf, bei uns gibt es aber hier mit
deinem Gesicht, gehst du alles durch,
du kriegst von uns schon die Biometriedaten und dann lässt du die Leute bitte
mit ihrem Gesicht in deine Airline oder sowas, in dein Flugzeug oder sowas.
Oder wie heißen diese Airlines, die obwohl man es nicht machen muss,
Ausweise kontrollieren, dass man denen sagt, okay pass auf, ihr lasst euch jetzt
nicht mehr den Ausweis und die Bordkarte zeigen, sondern wir haben ein Gesichtssystem.
Diesen Standard, den kriegst du auch einfach weltweit nicht etabliert. Also davon,
allein dadurch, denke ich, ist ein derartiges System zum Scheitern verurteilt,
weil das internationale Luftfahrtgewerbe das in Jahrzehnten nicht hingekriegt
hat, sich da auf einen neuen Standard zu einigen.
Und wenn jetzt irgendwelche Deutschen sagen, wir haben ein geiles Gesetz,
wir machen das alles mit dem Gesicht, das wird nicht ohne weiteres tragfähig sein.
Und da werden auch potenziell internationale Airlines nicht so einfach mitmachen,
als dass jetzt wirklich ein ganzer Wirtschaftszweig davon einen Vorteil hätte.
Vielleicht hat der Flughafen einen Vorteil, weil er sagt, geil,
die Leute sind eine Minute länger in unserem bescheuerten Shop und kaufen mehr ein oder sowas.
Aber ich halte es für nicht so leicht vorstellbar, dass du im System der internationalen
Luftfahrt neue Standards einführst, weil du dir irgendwie überlegt hast,
das machen wir jetzt mit dem Gesicht.
Du meinst wahrscheinlich diesen PNR-Code, der ist meistens sechsstellig,
manchmal sieben- oder achtstellig, meistens sechsstellig.
Diese alphanumerische, so X7K.
Es ging mir primär darum, dass es...
Dass sich dieses System seit vielen, vielen Jahrzehnten nicht mehr nennenswert
weiterentwickelt hat, weil es ein weltweiter Standard ist.
Ja gut, ich denke der Bundesregierung geht es hier im Wesentlichen um den Prozess
im Flughafen und irgendwie träumen sie davon,
dass wenn jetzt die Airlines am Flughafen unsere Ausweise digital auslesen dürfen,
dass in irgendeiner Form der Check-In schneller vorangeht.
Ich muss aber sagen, aus meiner persönlichen Erfahrung von Check-In bei inländischen
oder innereuropäischen Flügen wüsste ich jetzt nicht, wo da irgendwo nennenswert
Zeit gespart werden sollte.
Also es ist irgendwie alles Quatsch eigentlich.
Genau, also es würde einfach Bürokratie abgebaut werden, wenn man künftig Wert
darauf legt, dass nur noch die Bordkarte vorgezeigt wird.
Und das war's. So der Ausweis wird nicht mehr gebraucht. Und wenn man zusätzlich
sparen möchte, kann man die Erhebung der Passenger Name Records vielleicht einstellen
und künftig nicht mehr mit der Polizei teilen. Da kann man dann nochmal etwas Geld sparen.
Ist auf jeden Fall jetzt vom Kabinett beschlossen worden gestern und ist im
Bundesrat eingegangen und muss jetzt noch durch die ganzen Lesungen durch.
Vielleicht tut sich da noch was.
Ist jetzt auf jeden Fall der Zeitpunkt, sich da einzubringen,
wenn das ein Thema für euch ist.
Ich habe mal hier auf dem Bundestagszusammenfasser verlinkt,
der das natürlich schon gelistet hat.
Du hast natürlich recht, der PNR-Code ist sechs Zeichen lang und ich glaube,
dass es irgendwie auch was mit den Datenbanken zu tun hatte und wie der Index
halt auf acht Zeichen limitiert war.
Irgendwie sowas.
Ja, da gibt es dann irgendwelche Mainframe-Legacy-Sachen oder sowas.
Aber ich wollte nur sagen, so etwas weltweit einzuführen wird schwierig.
Und ich bin mal gespannt, wie viele internationale Airlines eure Sonderlocken dann noch mitspielen.
Ja, aber wie setzt man denn was international durch? Man macht richtig einen
dicken Max und droht mit Strafzöllen und so weiter.
Und so geht wohl gerade auch die USA hier vor und will jetzt irgendwie all.
Die Daten einfach direkt haben.
Einfach alles geben lassen. Her damit. Was ist da los?
Ja, wir bleiben beim Thema Fliegen. Manche von uns haben sich vielleicht länger
entschieden, nicht in die USA zu reisen, weil man da alle möglichen biometrischen
Daten, Fingerabdrücke, Gesichtsbilder und so weiter abgeben muss.
Dieser Grund ist künftig hinfällig. Wir können wieder in die USA reisen,
denn die EU möchte den direkten Zugriff auf nationale Polizeidatenbanken mit
den biometrischen Informationen preisgeben.
Das heißt, Sie kriegen das also, ob ich da hinfliege oder nicht?
Also mir würden ja noch tausend andere Gründe einfallen, da nicht hinzufliegen,
aber das ist natürlich jetzt krass.
Also wie ist das jetzt angedacht, dass man in dem Moment, wo man eine Reise
in die USA gebucht hat, im Prinzip die ganzen Daten bereits übermittelt werden?
Oder möchten die einfach mal sowieso alles haben von allen?
Ich weiß nicht, wie die Schnittstellen da aussehen, ob das auch irgendwie kontrolliert
wird. Vielleicht bekommen die USA dann einfach eine Live-Kopie.
Und das ist jetzt gerade in Verhandlungen zwischen der EU und den USA.
Genau, da ist die EU-Kommission, glaube ich, am Verhandeln mit den USA,
um vielleicht niedrigere Strafzölle beim nächsten Mal rauszuhandeln.
Also es geht um das Enhanced Border Security Partnership System und da kannst
du, wenn dein Land da mitmacht,
dann kannst du irgendwie visafrei einreisen, 90 Tage und so.
Aber damit sie das machen, sagen sie, ja, dann wollen wir schon dann aber auch
einfach einen Direktzugriff auf die nationalen Polizeidatenbanken mit den biometrischen,
Informationen haben. Ist ja einfacher, weißt du?
Achso, spart wahrscheinlich auch Geld für die Wirtschaft.
Entbürokratisierung.
Das entbürokratisieren die mal für dich, ne?
Mit die machen die automatisierte Abfragen.
Geil. Aber das ist nur die erste Stufe.
Das macht vieles einfacher. Wenn wir jetzt dabei sind, Polizeidatenbanken in
Deutschland zusammenzuführen und vielleicht Palantir zu geben,
dann kann das einfach Palantir in den USA direkt machen.
Dann haben auch die USA Zugriff und es wird alles einfacher.
Die Dänen haben gesagt, sie haben keinen Bock drauf.
Aber die haben jetzt auch Grönland abgegeben, oder?
Ja genau, das heißt Grönland ist vorbei.
Also diese, ich finde es in Summe dann doch sehr beeindruckend,
weil sich bei all dieser Datensammelwut,
die zu Recht...
In den letzten Jahrzehnten immer kritisiert wurde,
eine entscheidende Sache geändert hat und das ist,
dass die sowohl in der klassischen Datenverarbeitung als auch in der Verarbeitung
mit neuronalen Modellen eben die Verarbeitungsmöglichkeiten stark vergrößert haben.
Du kannst mit diesen Datenmengen jetzt etwas anfangen.
Diese Regel, wir suchen eine Nadel, wir brauchen mehr Heu,
die funktioniert jetzt auf einmal wirklich, weil du mit mehr Datenmengen tatsächlich
mit mehr Heu wirklich auch mehr Nadeln findest, statt die Nadel besser zu verstecken.
Insofern finde ich diese Zusammenführung von Daten, du hattest gerade schon
Palantir angesprochen, deren Spezialität es ist,
nicht gleich oder nicht einheitlich strukturierte Daten in Zusammenhänge zu
bringen, Was eine mit klassischen Herangehensweisen,
relationale Datenbanken und so eben sehr schwierig ist.
Mergen, Konflikte auflösen und so.
Darauf haben die sich spezialisiert, Daten in den unterschiedlichsten Formaten
irgendwie miteinander in Bezug zu bringen.
Geht mal gut, geht mal nicht gut, aber vor allem können sie mit diesen Datenmengen
irgendwie umgehen und das ausreichend genug,
dass man ja, sagen wir mal, Polizeibehörden, Überwacher und sonstige damit irgendwie
beeindrucken kann, statt einfach nur zu sagen, okay, scheiße,
ist zu viel, kommt da halt irgendetwas raus.
Klar, dann wird mal irgendwie die falsche Mädchenschule im Iran bombardiert,
das ist dann ein bedauerlicher Fehler gewesen, aber das System als Es hat ja
erstmal funktioniert, es hat ja gesagt, wir sollen das Ding da bombardieren.
Und da hat sich, denke ich,
schon eigentlich so in den letzten fünf bis acht Jahren etwas fundamental geändert,
was die Massenüberwachung angeht, dass jetzt wirklich überhaupt erstmal möglich wird.
Ich blicke in betreten schweigende Gesichter.
Ja, da hast du natürlich recht. Also alles, was jetzt theoretisch machbar ist,
wird natürlich jetzt auch getan.
Ich versuche jetzt gerade noch ein bisschen zu verstehen, was sie jetzt hier
eigentlich wirklich vorhaben.
Also soweit ich den Entwurf hier interpretiere, ist es halt so,
dass sie jetzt erstmal sagen, Ja, wenn was nicht stimmt, dann können natürlich
sofort per Realtime diese Daten abgefragt werden.
Also wir reden hier schon von einer Live-Verbindung.
Ja, Direktzugriff.
Und dieses Konzept von, ja nur, wenn es wirklich einen Anlass gibt.
Das wissen wir ja, wie wenig Anlass in den USA derzeit ausreicht,
um von irgendjemand Informationen rauszuholen.
Du kannst ja mal Eis fragen, was als Anlass reicht, dir einen Sack über den
Kopf zu ziehen, nämlich einen taktischen Kleinbus zu zerren.
Wir hatten einen Anlass.
Genau, also ich meine, wenn man schon mit faschistischen Staaten zu tun hat,
warum nicht gleich noch eine Realtime-Api dazu?
Das ist ja auch gleich weit von den Hollerit-Maschinen entfernt.
Und genau, und hier werden ja Fingerabdrücke weitergegeben etc. Also das ist...
Ich würde sagen, etwas ungeil. Wir haben Sendungstitel.
Ja, das ist ein bisschen ungeil. Ich muss sagen, ich verstehe da die EU-Kommission
an der Stelle jetzt nicht, weil man sich hier ganz offensichtlich einem Druck beugt.
Ich kann mir jetzt nicht vorstellen, dass das Interesse auf der EU-Seite nach
solchen Informationen und solchen
Realtime-Zugriffen genauso groß ist wie jetzt auf der Seite der USA.
Die wollen wahrscheinlich einfach nur die einfache Einreise weiterhin haben,
die wahrscheinlich daran geknüpft wird und künftig nicht einen Visumsantrag stellen wollen. Genau.
Und das ist so ein bisschen das Drohpotenzial.
Aber ich finde, da müsste sich die EU eigentlich jetzt anders aufstellen und
sagen, Leute, ja, okay, Visa und so.
Wenn ihr überhaupt noch wollt, dass jemand zu euch kommt, es fliegen ja schon
nicht mehr so viele rüber, dann denkt euch doch mal was anderes aus.
Was macht eigentlich die Überwachungsgesamtrechnung?
Es ist beim theoretischen und praktischen Maximum angekommen.
Die Überwachungsgesamtrechnung hat auf jeden Fall exponentiellen Charakter.
Und im Rahmen des Bürokratieabbaus kommt das auch nicht wieder vor. Abgeschafft. Ja.
Einige Hörerinnen waren auch dort.
Ich hatte über diesen gesamten Themenbereich KI-Überwachung eine kleine Folge Funfacts aufgenommen.
Schwerpunkt ein bisschen auch auf Erhalt der Demokratie, ein bisschen auf Palantir,
Alex K., Peter Thiel und was auch für Menschen daran arbeiten.
Den Begriff des Palantir nochmal,
aufgearbeitet. Den Link gibt es in den Shownotes.
Die Inhalte haben wir jetzt gerade eh nochmal in Ruhe mit Kantorkel besprochen.
Was ich an dem Abend ganz lustig fand, dass auch Oliver Kalkofe da war.
Und zwar nicht nur im Publikum, was ja klar ist, sondern auch an dem Abend wurde
auch eine Folge mit Oliver Kalkofe aufgezeichnet und es gab einen im Publikum,
für den war das die Sternstunde und das war Tim.
Du bist großer Oliver-Kalkofe-Fan.
Ja, bin ich schon immer gewesen.
Bin ich tief geprägt.
Und ich muss sagen, ich hatte erst, als du hießt, Oliver Kalkhofer,
habe ich gesagt, schwierige Generation, Boomer, ne?
Der hatte ja übrigens einen Podcast mit dem Oliver Welke, mit dem er ja eh schon
seit Jahrzehnten zusammenarbeitet.
Und dieser Podcast heißt Kalk und Welk, die fabelhaften Boomer Boys.
Allein da schon Humor. Und auch da denkst du so, boah, hoffentlich nicht.
Ich weiß, jetzt kommt da noch so ein Dieter Nur dazu und dann,
aber da würde ich sagen, da war der Oliver Kalkofe schon aus einem ganz anderen
Holz, was er da nachher noch in seinem,
Kapitel, was er da vorgelesen hat aus seinem Buch und so, das scheint schon einer von uns zu sein.
Also vielleicht nochmal so kurz Setup, wovon du jetzt berichtest,
ist die Veranstaltung, die wir hier natürlich in der letzten Sendung schon angekündigt
haben. Wie ist das Theater noch gleich?
Mehringhoftheater.
Mehringhoftheater, genau. Mehringdamme Berlin. Kreuzberg 61,
wie man sagt, unter Buhmann.
Kennst du, ne?
Ist das schon 61?
Ja, das ist so 61.
Weil Curry 36 gegenüber ist.
Das hat damit aber nichts zu tun. Das ist nur, weil es der Hausnummer 36 ist.
Das ist das tiefste, das ist Bettmannstraße.
Du hast schon recht, da muss irgendwo die Grenze sein. Die muss da irgendwo verlaufen.
Aber schon wahrscheinlich früher. Irgendwo am Halleschen Tor oder so.
Ja, das ist einfach, genau. Also wer die 36 und 61 unterschiedlich kennt in
Berlin, das ist so ein altes Ding, das bezieht sich auf dieses frühere Zustellpostamt,
als ganz Berlin noch dieselbe Postleitzahl hatte, warum auch immer, alles war 1000,
aber weil es dann doch für Berlin ein bisschen undivers war,
hat man dann eben Zustellpostbezirke gemacht, die man noch hinter den Namen schrieb.
Also wenn du nach Kreuzberg was schicken wolltest, dann musst du 1000 Berlin 36 schreiben.
Das haben sie dann später mit 5.
War nicht nur in Berlin so. Ja, die bei weitem nicht so große Stadt wie Berlin,
in der ich aufgewachsen bin, da gab es dann auch nochmal eine Zahl dahinter.
Okay, gut, wusste ich nicht. Auf jeden Fall war das so und deswegen unterscheidet
man heute diese beiden Kreuzbergs.
Das ist etwas punkigere 36 und das ein bisschen bürgerlichere 61.
Nur Köln war 44, ne?
Ja, nur in Kreuzberg definiert man sich über diese Ziffern.
Das ist übrig geblieben.
Ja, man muss ja irgendwie dann auch noch innerhalb von Kreuzberg differenzieren. Ja, klar.
Weil du gesagt hast, die wohnen in Kreuzberg. So, nee, nee, nee, 61, 61.
Erst nur 36.
Für manche ist natürlich auch die 61 eher die abschreckendere Zahl gewesen.
Da trennen sich so ein bisschen die Meinungen. Wie auch immer.
Auf jeden Fall habe ich jetzt auch mal gesehen, wie das so alles abläuft.
Also es ist ja so ein kleines Theater.
In 61 meinst du?
Jetzt.
Ich habe jetzt mal angeguckt.
Wie das da ist.
So in 61. Der fahrt die Autos auch auf der rechten Seite.
Das war es dann aber auch schon mit den Gemeinsamkeiten. Nein,
nein. Ich meine natürlich, wie das mit den Funfacts abläuft.
Und ja, das...
War dann quasi so eine Live-Fernsehaufzeichnung, muss man sagen.
Und ihr musstet ja erstmal, du musstest auf jeden Fall erstmal ganz schön schwitzen.
Da hat man schon gemerkt, dass ein bisschen Erfahrung in dem Metier hilft sehr.
Also wenn man sich angeschaut hat, wie der Oliver Kalkofe da souverän durch
seinen Kopf durchmarschiert ist.
Aber klar, der macht das jeden Tag und das schon seit ich weiß nicht wann.
Und dass er mit Oliver Welke zusammen was macht, überrascht mich halt mal so
gar nicht, weil Oliver Welke gehört ja noch zu dieser Ursprungstruppe dem Frühstücksradio.
Damit fing das ja mal an und deswegen bin ich da auch so krass geprägt,
weil das war ja Hannover.
Die haben das erste Privatradio in Deutschland bespielt, wo alle dachten,
oh die CDU hat Privatradio beschlossen, was kommt jetzt?
Aber Hannover 36, ne?
Tja, nee, das war alles 3000. Wie auch immer, auf jeden Fall Oliver Welke,
Kalkofe, gehörten zu diesem ursprünglichen Team und wen man wahrscheinlich auch noch kennt,
ist Dietmar Wischmeier, waren noch ein paar andere dabei, auf jeden Fall war
das eine geile Truppe und die haben einfach damals einen Humor an den Tag gelegt
mit diesem Frühstücksradio, das hat einfach Hannover im Sturm erobert und sie
waren also da schon absolute Legende.
Humoristisch war Hannover jetzt auch immer relativ sturmreif, oder?
Unterschätzt heißt das. Unterschätzt. Naja, ich meine, das war ja,
glaube ich, auch das besonders komische daran, dass ja Hannover eigentlich immer als,
langweilig wahrgenommen wird. Das war immer so ein bisschen so dieses Ding.
Ich erinnere mich noch gut, ich hatte irgendwann mal im Spiegel gab es so einen
Artikel über die langweiligste Stadt Deutschlands.
Hannover, ja. Nee, Nürnberg.
Nürnberg?
Ja, der Spiegelartikel.
Da ist doch mit den Nürnberger Prozessen mal richtig pep reingekommen in den Laden.
Ja, deswegen, also der Spiegelartikel machte sich also auf jeden Fall über Nürnberg
her und erklärte, warum Nürnberg so furchtbar langweilig ist und überhaupt und so weiter.
Und dann so zwei Ausgaben später, das war so damals noch die typische Turnaround-Zeit,
gab es dann so einen Leserbrief.
Da beschwerte sich Hannover.
Und dann beschwerte sich eine Frau aus Hannover und meinte so,
ja, sie hätte ja nichts dagegen, dass diese Diskussion über die langweiligste
Stadt in Deutschland geführt werden würde, aber sie würde doch den Spiegel bitten,
sich dann doch auch endlich mal festzulegen.
In Hannover hätte man sich schon längst daran gewöhnt, diesen Titel zu tragen
und solche Artikel würden sie einfach nur verwirren.
Sie möchten das doch bitte unterlassen.
Und das trifft wiederum den Humor von Hannover sehr gut.
Genauso wie Kalkofe und der Rest vom Frühstücksradio, diesen Humor dort getroffen
haben und es war einfach hilarious.
Und von daher konnte ich auch was er dann vorgelesen hat, war ja aus seinem
Buch und das reflektierte einfach auch so seine Generation, die dann auch meine
Generation ist, so gut ich hab mich echt weggeschmissen.
Das war so komisch das war wirklich super da hat er wirklich enorm getroffen und da hab ich auch,
sehr gut gelacht vor allem, weil er ist einfach enorm gut beobachtet und super
vorgelesen also was mir da ich habe das ja zum ersten Mal gemacht,
so was, ja, was mir da aufgefallen ist,
ist wie viel mehr Dynamik,
und Ausdruck man in so eine Vorführung bieten kann.
Während ich dann so, hier mal ein bisschen mit der Stimme und er dann über einen
viel größeren Bandbreitenbereich arbeitet und ja, war wirklich auch,
beeindruckend, so einen Profi mal zu sehen und abgesehen davon wirklich auch
super nett und ja, die Folge, die mit Oliver Kalkofe war,
haben wir auch mal verlinkt, der hat sich mit Milliardären die rechte Medien News.
Finanzieren auseinandergesetzt und danach hatte dann der Stefan vom Zentrum
für politische Schönheit noch einen Auftritt wer jemals einen Vortrag von Stefan
gesehen hat, weiß, dass da auch kein Auge trocken bleibt.
Mein Favorite war dann irgendwie so dass Marc-Uwe Kling, der durch den Abend
geführt hat, dann irgendwie so Stefan abmoderierte,
und dann fragte irgendjemand aus der ersten, Stefan hatte sein Mikrofon schon
ab und dann fragte irgendjemand aus der ersten,
zweiten Reihe noch so eine Frage und Stefan hat dann einfach die Frage beantwortet,
stand einfach weiter auf der Bühne und gewatschte dann noch und der Stimme war ja eh laut genug,
dass es auch einfach weiter gemacht hat, während die Bühne umgebaut wurde für Esels Albtraum,
den Hörerinnen von Logbuch Netzpolitik und insbesondere Besucherinnen von LNP
500 sicherlich in guter Erinnerung.
Das war wirklich ein echt schöner Abend was mich zu dem Fazit bringt natürlich
könnt ihr auch, meine Folge habe ich auch in 100 könnt ihr euch angucken,
Fun Facts ich finde das wirklich ein richtig cooles Projekt, ja,
Es ist Community-finanziert, also wo kriegen die ihre Kohle her?
Du wirst entweder Bandenmitglied oder, also damit, das heißt,
eine regelmäßige Spenderin oder du kaufst Tickets oder du kaufst Klopapier.
Das sind so die drei finanziellen Säulen, auf denen das steht.
Die Menschen, die da mitmachen, machen das alles unentgeltlich.
Dafür wird das Team bezahlt, das Team von Fun Facts.
Wirklich auch großartige Leute, wirklich gute Leute, die dieses Ding da mit
Herzblut machen und dann auch so Amateure wie mich dadurch betreuen.
Dass dann irgendwie ein Writers Room ist, wo Leute sagen, guck mal Linus,
wir versuchen das jetzt mal witzig zu machen und dann bei Supporten so ein Ding
zu schreiben und das finde ich schon wirklich, ja muss ich sagen, finde ich echt spitze.
Ja, und es ist ja auch, das hast du auch, finde ich, gut gemacht.
Also es kam einfach super rüber.
Ich habe mir das Ergebnis auch nochmal angeschaut. Das ist schon cool.
Also gutes Ergebnis, muss ich sagen, für die geringe Stolperung über Sachen.
Also manchmal passt das Lachen des Publikums nicht.
Ja, das war klar, dass du wieder mit dem Lachen verkacken, ey.
Scheiß Publikum.
Ne, ich sag nur, es können so viele Dinge schief gehen, so, und dann verhaspelt
man sich. Ich weiß nicht, wie leicht das ist, von diesem Promptor abzulesen.
Sehr viel leichter, als ich dachte. Also das war meine größte Sorge,
muss ich echt sagen, dass die sich, dass es da eben dieses, diesen Textlesen,
den eine andere Person scrollt.
Ja.
Das war meine...
Die wird von Hand gescrollt, oder? Ja.
Da sitzt dann, in dem Fall war das Lea, die,
sitzt dann da und scrollt dieses Ding, liest das live mit und das ist natürlich
ein Programm, was dafür geeignet ist.
Das ist jetzt nicht irgendwie ein nervöses Scroll mit so einem Thinkpad-roten
Button oder sowas, sondern das ist schon dafür geeignet, leserlich in diesem
Scroll-Vorgang zu bleiben.
Und das habe ich mir enorm schwierig vorgestellt.
Aber weil dieser Promptor weit genug weg ist, dass du jetzt nicht groß mit den
Augen wackeln muss, ist das also diese Sorge war so 5-6 Meter weg.
Ja, in deinem Alter wird das dann ein Problem.
Wieso?
Achso, ne, du werdet ja alle weitsichtig. Ja, so auch nicht.
Ne, also das war meine größte Sorge und das hat sich, diese Sorge hat sich als
unbegründet herausgestellt.
Es ist aber dann eben auch sehr wichtig, genau in diesem Skript zu bleiben.
Weil natürlich dann an anderer Stelle eine Person ist, die diesen Screen dahinter
bedient und genau weiß, wann jetzt da hinten dieser Screen, wann dann das Bild hinter mir erscheint.
Und dafür ist eben auch wichtig, dass ich genau den Text mache und nicht irgendwie
sage, ich habe mir überlegt, ich weiche mal davon ab oder so.
So wie Donald Trump, der dann irgendwann sagt, heute erzähle ich euch mal von,
das ging nicht, also dieses Mal noch nicht.
Aber ja, das war meine größte Sorge, dann kompletten Text ablesen zu müssen
und dabei lebhaft zu bleiben und das war bei weitem kein Problem.
Trotzdem hat natürlich der Oliver Kalkofe nochmal gezeigt wie man mit ein paar
Jahren Erfahrung mit so einem Ding umgeht aber was ich noch erwähnen wollte
ich finde dieses Konzept eben deshalb cool,
weil es Menschen wie Oliver Kalkofe, Oliver Welke, Marc-Uwe Klingen,
ungefähr alle Comedians, die man kennt,
gibt, die da mitmachen dann für die Amateure den Support,
hinstellen, dass ich da auch in der Lage bin mitzumachen oder Anne Brohr-Hilker,
ich hatte schon Raul Krauthausen und wer alles da schon war und dass das dann
auch gemischt wird und das finde ich, das ist wirklich einfach ein super Ding
und die Folge von Raul wollte ich auch nochmal empfehlen, weil der,
also auch ein Beispiel ist für einen weiteren Nicht-Profi-Comedian der dann
wirklich super Dinge hingelegt hat und es geht um.
Barrierefreiheit das Leben von Menschen mit Behinderung und das ist auch einfach
super runtergerockt, was er da gemacht hat.
Und an dem Kontext nochmal zu erwähnen ist sowieso sein Engagement bei den Sozialhelden
und mit dem Accessibility-Score, der auf Open Data setzt.
Um so quasi auf großer Menge für Städte,
So Scoring zu machen, was habt ihr denn da alles? Wie accessible ist diese Stadt?
Und das setzt sehr viel auf, auf Tags und Daten, die in OpenStreetMap-Layern hinterlegt werden.
Und das finde ich sehr cool, weil wir ja in unserer Community und in unserer
Hörerinnenschaft sicherlich viele Open Data und Open Street Map Enthusiastinnen
haben und wenn ihr euch da mal den Accessibility Score anschaut und das Tagging,
was da vorgeschlagen ist,
da lässt sich eine Menge an wirklich brauchbaren Daten hinterlegen,
die, und das ist eben auch so eines der Fazite, die man aus der Fun Facts Folge mit Raul,
zieht diese ganzen barrierelevanten.
Daten sind nicht nur für Menschen mit Behinderungen relevant,
sondern die haben sehr, sehr viel Bezug für alle.
Und was ich am schönsten fand, ist, dass man gesagt hat, Maßnahmen der Barrierefreiheit
haben noch nie irgendjemand anderes behindert.
Das heißt, wenn wir jetzt auf Barrierefreiheit hinarbeiten und erfassen und das ermöglichen,
das ist jetzt nicht so, als würde man dagegen sein eigenes Interesse arbeiten und sagen, oh nein,
jetzt machen die da auch noch die Barriere weg und demnächst kann mein Ehemann
da mit dem Kinderwagen oder ich mit dem geklauten Einkaufswagen auf dem Rückweg
vom Flohmarkt oder einem besoffenen Kumpel vorne drin da auch besser lagen.
Also das ist ja wirklich nicht so, als wäre das etwas, was den Rest der Bevölkerung
in irgendeiner Weise das Leben erschwert, sondern auch für die Erleichterungen bringt.
Und allein wenn der schildert, die anderen Leute mit mir im Fahrstuhl,
den gefällt der ja offenbar auch.
Das sind schon einfach, die ist super geworden.
Ja, ich habe mit Raul hatte ich ja schon… Vor vielen Jahren CRE gemacht. Genau.
Über Wheelmap, das war so das erste Projekt, was in diese Accessibility-Richtung
und Nutzung von offenen Daten ging.
Das Projekt gibt es ja auch heute noch, also OpenStreetMap erweitert,
um eben diese Accessibility-Aspekte, speziell eben von Rollstuhlfahrern,
aber seitdem hat er ja so viel gemacht, er ist so ein krasser Aktivist und wenn man ihn so sieht,
wenn man sich so begegnet, denkt man sich so, wie machst du das?
Die Energie einfach cooler Typ.
Also die auch und dann könnt ihr sicherlich noch viele andere Folgen finden
und Bandenmitglied werden das Finanzieren ist ja,
ähnlich wie bei uns finanziert sich nur aus den Leuten, die Bock haben dafür
zu bezahlen und das irgendwie einfach mit zu supporten, damit es passiert,
Ähm, ja. Achso, und natürlich, Fun Facts, ich sage immer, sie veröffentlichen primär Fediverse.
Es gibt also eine Peertube-Instanz, wo es die ganzen Videos gibt,
aber natürlich bespielen sie auch die zentralen sozialen Medien wie YouTube und so,
aber da könnt ihr auch so richtig schön mal in eurem Peertube und im Fediverse und was nicht alles,
dann ist da alles einfach nativ drin, das ist die Basis.
Dann stimmt's auch mit der Fairdiversity.
Ja, und wenn da mal irgendwie demnächst AWS abgeschaltet wird oder was,
dann haben wir immer noch einen Server hin, einen deutschen Server in der D-NIC Rootzone.
Gibt's nicht immer eine Adresse für?
Nee, also cooles Ding, hab ich jetzt glaube ich oft genug gesagt,
aber einmal sag ich's noch, echt cool. Fun Facts ist gut.
Dann war ja mir wieder DIT, Digital Independence Day, da haben jetzt die Grüne,
Linke und SPD kehren X den Rücken und die erste Frage, die ich mir gestellt
habe, macht Karl Lauterbach mit?
Und? Nein.
Weiß ich nicht.
Wieso?
Ich bin ja nicht mehr bei X, ich kann es nicht kontrollieren.
Weißt du das, Kantorkel?
Keine Ahnung.
Aber Karl Lauterbach war dagegen, oder?
Weiß ich nicht.
Hab ich gelesen.
Dagegen war der auf jeden Fall.
Ich weiß aber auch nicht mehr. X.com, Karl Lauterbach wahrscheinlich, ne?
Äh, keine Ahnung.
Der ist noch da.
Ja.
Aber postet er noch?
Vor 23 Stunden.
Äh, äh.
Ich bin auf dem Fake-Account jetzt, glaube ich. Oder der hat viel weniger Follower, als ich dachte.
Ne, hier genau. 1,2 Millionen Follower.
Tja, die gibt man nicht einfach mal so eben ab.
Hier privat.
Nicht als SPD-Mitglied.
Auf jeden Fall, ja vielleicht auch, also die Frage kann man sich ja schon mal stellen,
warum man, wenn man jetzt alle Fluggastdaten und Polizeidatenbanken den Amerikanern
geben möchte, warum man darüber dann ausgerechnet auf der Plattform von Elon Musk tweeten muss.
Und natürlich freuen wir uns über diese Bewegung in Richtung Digital Independence,
den DIT, der ja auch gerade wieder am Wochenende war, der erste Sonntag im Monat.
Und bei der Gelegenheit wollte ich mal noch so ein paar andere DIT-Seiten oder
DIT-Kontext-Seiten erwähnen, die sich seitdem gebildet haben.
Zum Beispiel lmaa.space.
Heißt?
Lokale Märkte, alternative Anbieter.
Dann kannst du sagen, ich möchte ein Buch kaufen und dann gibt es eben lokale
Märkte und alternative Anbieter dazu.
Okay.
Und ja, das finde ich auf jeden Fall mal eine spannende Seite.
Ah, das kann ich echt mal erzählen.
Ich gehe erst die Seiten durch, aber möchte ich mal von einem Einkauf erzählen,
den ich gemacht habe im Internet.
Dann gibt es die Seite dday.fedyserve.de, wo einfach,
du sagst so, ich benutze diesen Service und dann gibt der dir eben unabhängigere,
nicht-Big-Tech-Alternativen dazu.
Und das im relativ großen Rahmen so.
Im Prinzip jetzt nicht mit irgendwelchen Anleitungen oder so,
sondern einfach nur so, was gibt's denn überhaupt so einen alternativen Picker
finde ich von der Usability ganz reizvoll,
da wird jetzt nicht lange rum erzählt oder so sondern einfach zack,
zeig mal klick, klack, bumm das finde ich auf jeden Fall super cool für die Orientierung,
Vielen unserer Hörerinnen bekannt ist ja sicherlich auch Mike Kuketz,
der unter Kuketz Blog sehr, sehr viel im Bereich Datenschutz,
Datensicherheit und so weiter postet und der hat,
wenn man da so einfach nach Hashtag Unplug sucht, da schreibt er dann immer
seine Anleitungen Unplug Big Tech, Unplug Trump und so weiter. wurde.
Und das sind dann sehr, finde ich, sehr brauchbare, ausführliche Anleitungen,
die das fundamental erklären.
Ja, und zu den Events gibt's dann den Terminkalender.
Dann gibt's noch eine Seite jetzt neu aus dem ccc-Kontext, dday.org.
Und da tut sich ein bisschen was. Ich hab auch übrigens dann noch den aus den
Niederlanden, den Duidach. Kennst du Duidach?
Ne, Duidach ist nämlich, also Dui, D-O-E-I-J geschrieben, glaube ich.
Dui ist niederländisch Tschüss. Und die haben den Duidach.
Der Tschüssdach. Wo sie dann auch das ähnliche Konzept angelehnt umsetzen.
Finde ich alles sehr schön.
Ich fand den letzten Sonntag sehr erfolgreich. Bei einer Verwandten haben wir
einen Rechner mit Ubuntu versehen.
Wir haben verschiedene Abos von PayPal wegmigriert.
Andere Abos US-amerikanischer Dienste haben wir ganz beendet und wir haben schon
vereinbart, als nächstes mal ein Handy mit Graphene OS zu versehen.
Und ja, ich bin sehr zufrieden mit dem letzten Sonntag.
Habt ihr Vero benutzt oder wohin seid ihr umgezogen?
Lastschrift.
Nicht sofort Überweisung.de,
Für mehr Datensouveränität geben sie hier den Zugang zu ihrem Konto ein. Lastschrift.de.
Nee, nicht die Lastschrift.
Achso, ganz einfach, wie sich das gehört.
Bankkonto Einzug, 2% Skonto. Ja, klassisch.
Ich habe, ich tue mich ja schwer,
einzelne Anbieter zu oder Shops oder so zu empfehlen, aber ich will echt mal
von einer Erfahrung berichten, die ich gemacht habe in einem Online-Shop, der nicht Amazon ist.
Und da habe ich ein Gerät bestellt, das war mir wichtig, das in schwarz zu haben.
Es handelte sich um eine HiFi-Komponente, ein Phonoverstärker.
Und den wollte ich gerne in schwarz. Ja, deswegen habe ich den in schwarz gekauft.
Und dann kam der in silber. Stand draußen schwarz drauf, aber drin war halt
ein silberner. Das ist also irgendein Problemchen.
Dann habe ich gesagt, ey, hier Leute, tut mir leid, da auf dem Karton steht
schwarz, ist aber ein Silberner drin, könnt ihr mir bitte den Schwarzen schicken,
den ich wollte, weil das ist alles schwarz, mir ist das wichtig mit dem Schwarz.
Ja, nee, Mensch, sorry, kein Problem, hier, Retoure-Label, alles gut,
zweites Paket kommt, mach ich auf, wieder ein Silberner drin.
So, dann hab ich geschrieben, boah Leute, sorry, und da stand auch wieder schwarz
drauf, ich sag, ey, es tut mir leid, was können wir da machen?
So und dann kommt, lieber Herr Neumann,
scheiße, tut uns total leid, ich hab jetzt die komplette Lieferkette durchtelefoniert,
es gibt den einfach nicht mehr in schwarz, mir ist unklar, warum der hier falsch
gelabelt bei uns liegt und es tut uns unglaublich leid.
Ich habe jetzt aber meine Händlerkollegen durchtelefoniert und einer hatte noch
einen Schwarzen, der ist jetzt schon auf dem Weg zu Ihnen.
Schicken Sie mir den zweiten Silbernen auch zurück. Sorry nochmal.
Ja und also da war halt ein Mensch am anderen Ende.
An dessen Ehre das auch gekratzt hat, der sich dann eingesetzt hat und ans Telefon
gegangen ist und bei einem anderen nicht eher Ruhe gegeben hat,
als dass ich das bekommen habe, was ich bestellt hatte.
Und ich will jetzt nicht wissen, also das war auf jeden Fall viel Arbeit und
persönlicher Einsatz und dann zwei Retouren, das hat alles gekostet.
Der hat da nichts mehr dran verdient und ich fand das einfach mal,
für mich war es eine super positive Erfahrung.
Und ja, da habe ich irgendwie gedacht, Mensch, guck mal,
bestellst du mal bei so einem einfachen Online-Händler außerhalb von Amazon
und da sind echt Menschen, die sich mit ihrer Arbeit Mühe geben.
Und das war nicht das erste Mal, dass ich eine solche Erfahrung gemacht habe
und das sage ich ganz ehrlich, als jemand, der sehr viel aus Prinzip und ich
will einfach keinen Ärger bei Amazon bestellt.
Asche auf mein Haupt, jetzt guckt hier wieder, ich gucke hier wieder in betretene
Gesichter, der bestellt bei Amazon.
Aber die Erfahrungen, die ich da gemacht habe, waren von besonders positiver
Prägung und das hat mich dann auch gefreut, dass ich mein Geld bei denen gelassen
habe und nicht da, wo keine Steuern am Ende gezahlt werden.
Deswegen verlinken wir natürlich auch jetzt hier genial lokal wenn wir nochmal
auf das Buch von Mark-Uwe Klingen aufmerksam machen und Hörbuch und,
E-Book in der natürlich auch dieser Dit-Aufruf nochmal nachzulesen ist für diejenigen,
die das Video noch nicht oft genug gesehen haben vom 39C3,
Signal wurde gehackt Matthias Oh.
Nein,
Scheiße Was machen wir?
Wer hat das gesagt?
Ey, also Signal Hack ist einfach das Ding.
Die gesamte Berichterstattung handelt von Signal wurde gehackt,
Bundestag will Signal verbieten, alle müssen zu einem sicheren Messenger,
der US-Anbieter Signal.
Und wir haben das Thema ja hier schon öfter behandelt, auch wie das passiert
ist. Es handelte sich um Social Engineering Angriffe.
Social Engineering Angriffe passieren in offenen Kommunikationsstrukturen.
E-Mail, irgendein Messenger, SMS, hast du alles nicht gesehen?
Das, wo dich die Welt erreichen kann, da wirst du eben auch mit falschen Identitäten getäuscht.
Dieses ganze Thema zieht sich jetzt schon seit mehreren Monaten durch die Signal-Accounts.
Wir haben ja schon öfter darüber gesprochen. Jetzt war dann eben auch Julia
Klöckner unter denjenigen,
die nicht nur eine solche Nachricht empfangen hat,
sondern dann eben auch in diesem Chat ihre PIN verraten hat und deren Account
dann übernommen wurde. Sie ist,
Bundestagspräsidentin. Seit einem Jahr, was übrigens heißt, diese gesamte Kabinett
März alles, das ist jetzt ein Jahr und mir kommt es ein bisschen länger vor.
Wollte ich nur sagen, es ist erst ein Jahr.
Also nicht so lange wie ein Jahr Trump.
Das wird noch anders gezählt, aber es sind auf jeden Fall, es war auf jeden Fall ein Hundejahr.
Naja, auf jeden Fall scheint Frau Glöckner in ihrem Amt, was ja,
wenn ich das richtig sehe, Platz zwei in diesem Staat ist, hat sie offensichtlich
noch keine Sicherheitsunterweisung erhalten.
Und das ist genau das Ding sie nicht nur,
benutzt die Signal was ihr ja erstmal als Privatperson durchaus gegönnt ist,
sondern sie benutzt es offenbar auch mit irgendwelchen, sie bilden darin irgendwelche
Fraktionsgruppen ab und so,
und dann hat sie offenbar nicht,
irgendwie die die,
das Verantwortungsbewusstsein,
diesen Messenger zu härten, zum Beispiel diese Account Verification und so weiter
einzuschalten, um sich gegen solche Angriffe und leichtfertiges Aufgeben des Zuganges zu schützen.
Da gibt es ja höhere Sicherheitseinstellungen, die man machen kann,
wenn man ein High-Risk-Individual ist.
Zum Beispiel die zweithöchste Person im Staat.
Da gehe ich noch mit, dass man das jetzt Julia Klöckner nicht persönlich vorwerfen
kann, das nicht von sich aus getan zu haben.
Ich denke aber schon, dass man ihr vorwerfen muss, sich nicht den Rat gesucht zu haben.
Oder nicht erhalten zu haben, das weiß ich nicht.
Oder den nicht erhalten zu haben. Und dann aber auf jeden Fall,
denke ich, muss man allen diesen,
ranghohen Politikerinnen, die ihre Politikerinnentätigkeit,
die innere, also quasi Fraktionsgruppe oder Koalitionsgruppe auf einem öffentlichen
Messenger abbilden, da muss man dann schon sagen, das ist Das ist ein Problem.
Und dafür haben Staaten normalerweise andere Kommunikationssysteme.
Irgendwelche ähm.
Dass ich wüsste.
Es gibt mehrere Anbieter in Deutschland die,
Kryptohandys spezifisch gehärtete Geräte mit geschlossenen Kommunikationspartnerinnen
ähm anbieten, ja, dann hast du das gibt es als App, das gibt es als Gerät,
das gibt es seit 20 Jahren, du weißt auch, kennst auch einen der Anbieter Der sitzt hier in Berlin,
ein anderer sitzt in München und die richten sich an genau so etwas.
Geheimdienste, Regierungsmitarbeiterinnen, Militär und wen auch immer.
Da, wo Kommunikation ein absolutes, besonderes Sicherheitsniveau haben muss.
Und wenn wir uns daran erinnern an die Huthi PC Small Group,
ja, wo der Hexeth war das, glaube ich, ne, mal eben noch auf Signal darüber
lästern wollte, bevor sie irgendwas bombardieren und versehentlich einen Journalisten
mit in die Gruppe genommen hat.
Genau deswegen hat man solche geschlossenen Kommunikationssysteme,
ja, in denen du dann zum Beispiel auch einstellen kannst, der General kann alle
anrufen, aber nicht jeder den General und so weiter und so fort, ja.
So etwas ist für die kritische,
regierungsinterne Kommunikation zu nutzen. Da gibt es auch gar keine Diskussion drüber.
Also sie ist ja technisch nicht Teil der Regierung.
Nur um das...
Okay.
Um den Kommentar, den wir jetzt bekommen, gleich zu...
Zum Glück ist sie technisch nicht Teil der Regierung.
Man könnte aber davon ausgehen, dass irgendjemand auf die leichtfertige Idee kommt,
schützenswerte Gesprächsinhalte mit Julia Klöckner austauschen zu müssen.
Auch wenn das wahrscheinlich grundsätzlich eine schlechte Idee ist.
Ja, ein bestimmtes Signal-Chat mit irgendjemand in der Regierung natürlich selbstverständlich.
Natürlich. Und genau das ist das Problem. Insofern habe ich dazu im Gespräch
mit der Süddeutschen Zeitung gesagt, nicht Signal, sondern Frau Klöckner wurde gehackt.
Das ist beim zweithöchsten Staatsamt ein erhebliches individuelles Versagen,
das aber in eine Struktur fällt, die es ermöglicht hat. Dieser zweite Satzteil ist sehr wichtig.
Es gibt strukturelle Probleme und die bestehen darin, dass es eben kein gehärtetes System ist.
Es gibt ein strukturelles Problem und das besteht darin, dass Signal kein gehärtetes
System für geschlossene Nutzergruppen ist und trotzdem offenbar flächendeckend
für interne Gruppen genutzt wurde.
Ich finde das ja völlig in Ordnung, dass beispielsweise Julia Klöckner Signal
auf dem Handy hat, um mit Journalistinnen zu kommunizieren, aber eben nicht
mit internen Regierungsgruppen.
Und dann gibt es eine Warnung vor unbekannten Kontakten, die wird standardmäßig
eingeblendet, die hat sie ignoriert,
dann gibt es eben auch weitere Sicherheitsfunktionen, die sie offenbar nicht
anhatte und zu deren Nutzung Hochrisikogruppen dringend geraten wird.
So weit so unverfänglich das Zitat, jetzt wird im weiteren Verlauf der Artikel
von einem anderen Redakteur,
gekürzt der zu dem Schluss kommt, dass es nicht so relevant ist den Teil beizubehalten
dass das Verhalten in eine Struktur fällt, die es ermöglicht hat und den Nebensatz kürzt.
Woraufhin sich Leute dann wiederum bei mir beschweren, dass ich Victim Blaming betreibe,
Weil ich, was fällt mir ein?
Und dann passiert auch noch so mein Traum.
Dieses Zitat nimmt dann Ronen Steinke und kommentiert darauf nochmal in einem Kommentar.
Ja, dann musste ich also leider bei der Süddeutschen sagen, ey Leute, komm,
ich hatte dieses Zitat, das war jetzt, und der Redakteur, mit dem ich gesprochen
hatte, sagte auch, Mensch, ja, ich hab's nicht gekürzt, scheiß,
das ist im weiteren Verlauf der Veröffentlichung, da gucken ja immer mehrere
KIs dann drauf, nein, mehrere Redakteure drauf,
bis es released wird, etwas unglücklich, ja.
Aber ich würde gerne zu diesem Thema Victim-Blaming auch nochmal was sagen.
Also Julia Klöckner ist leider nicht irgendjemand, sondern sie hat eine Verantwortung
und der muss sie gerecht werden.
Da ist ein Unterschied, ob der Tim jetzt hier auf den Signal-Phishing reinfällt
oder eine sehr zentrale Person in unserem Staat.
Und wenn sie das nicht selbst kann, dann hat sie eben diesen gesamten Staatsapparat
mit Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz, BSI und wenig alles und wie viele Mitarbeiterinnenpauschale und so weiter.
Sie hat alle Ressourcen, um irgendjemanden zu finden, der sagt,
komm, Frau Klöckner, wir machen mal eben, dass das hier so und so ist.
Und sie hätte auch ein vernünftiges, besonders geertetes Gerät bekommen können und so weiter.
Das nicht zu nutzen, da würde ich sagen, da fängt die Verantwortungslosigkeit dann an.
Und es ist ja auch nicht so, dass sie irgendjemand gezwungen hat,
Regierungs- oder staatsinterne Gruppen auf diesen Messenger abzubilden. Ähm.
Dieser Aspekt kam mir in der Diskussion ein bisschen zu kurz,
weil es ist absolut richtig, wenn die jetzt sagen, okay, wir haben andere Messenger
mit hoffentlich geschlossenen Nutzergruppen, die wir verwenden.
Ich glaube, dass sie da jetzt Wire nutzen und ich bin mir sicher,
dass Wire auch so ein Tenant-basiertes System hat, wo du eine geschlossene Benutzerinnengruppe
machen kannst. Matthias holt Luft.
Ja, ich finde die Frage, war es jetzt eine bewusste Entscheidung,
Signal zu nutzen, sehr interessant, denn vielleicht war es voller Absicht,
Signal zu nutzen, denn eigentlich muss ja dienstliche Kommunikation auch der
Bundestagsverwaltung und der Bundestagspräsidentin archiviert werden.
Bei Signal kann man aber versehentlich, genauso wie Frau von der Leyen oder um Platz zu sparen,
Nachrichten automatisch löschen lassen, sodass Frag den Staat nicht in die Verlegenheit
kommt, solche dokumentierte Kommunikation anzufragen.
Insofern kann man ihr da vielleicht schon auch mehr Absicht unterstellen.
Ich finde das sehr schön, dass du das ansprichst, weil nämlich fragt den Staat
damals den SMS-Wechsel zwischen Kanzlerin Merkel und EU-Kommensationspräsidentin
von der Leyen angefragt hat und so weiter und weil...
Dadurch, dass fragt den Staat natürlich berechtigterweise gerne Akten und die
darin vorkommenden Aktennotizen anfragt und erhält,
es dann auch den einen oder anderen Anekdote gibt, wo sich dann auf einmal immer weniger findet.
Ja, weil die Behörden und die Regierungen und die Behördenchefinnen und die
Bundestagspräsidentinnen in so eine Schatten-IT flüchten, wo man Disappearing
Messages einstellt und einfach auf dem Privathandy ist.
Und sich so auch, und das ist ja glaube ich das, was da ein bisschen rausklingt,
potenziell den Informationsfreiheits- und Transparenzrechten und Ansprüchen
der Bürgerinnen und Bürger entziehen kann.
Und genau deswegen habe ich nicht so viel,
Mitgefühl jetzt. Was?
Echt? Mensch, die arme Julia.
Auf einer empathischen Ebene tut es mir leid.
Aber vor allem für die 80 Millionen Bürgerinnen, die in diesem Staat,
leben.
War das jetzt soft genug?
Wir können ja mal die archivierte Signal Kommunikation anfragen und insbesondere
die Phishing-Nachricht.
Oh ja, das machen wir gleich noch. Bin ich mal gespannt, ob wir das kriegen.
Ja, aber ich habe schon den Eindruck, da gibt es natürlich jetzt auch hier beispielsweise
von Falk Steiner und anderen,
auch auf Heise habe ich da auch natürlich dann Ul Golem von hier von unterschiedlichen
Leuten natürlich auch die Kommentare und Einlassungen gesehen, aber,
das ist für mich schon ein Beispiel von einem, von einer öffentlichen Debatte, die,
ziemlich am Kern der Sache vorbeigeht. Davon haben wir viele.
Das ist eine davon.
So. Und wir haben ein Thema, wir verlieren einen Themenkomplex, Tim. Und zwar für immer.
Einen sagen so, anderen sagen so.
Ich denke schon, ein bisschen.
Vor 30 Jahren,
begann, also da hat der Diesel 60 Pfennig gekostet, zu dieser Zeit.
Wow.
Also glaube ich jetzt, 30 Jahre.
Sag lieber, was eine Kugel Eis gekostet hat.
Eine Kugel Eis hast du umsonst bekommen. Die wurde dir einfach geschenkt vom netten Onkel.
Ach komm. Quatsch.
Vor 30 Jahren, meine Güte, was war vor 30 Jahren? Also da bin ich zur Schule gegangen.
Ja, deswegen weiß man ja auch, was eine Kugel Eis kostet.
Das wusste ich gar nicht. Ich hatte noch gar kein Geld. Die gab es einfach,
wenn man lange genug gequengelt hat.
Also ich kann dir sagen, was vor 50 Jahren noch eine Kugel Eis gekostet hat.
Nee, das ist jetzt vor 30 Jahren.
Ja, okay. Das habe ich mir nicht gemerkt. Da mochte ich kein Eis mehr.
Vor 30 Jahren gab es einen Menschen, den gibt es wahrscheinlich immer noch, Moses Pelham,
mir vor allem bekannt dafür, dass er Stefan Rath mal die Nase gebrochen hat
und ansonsten wohl sich musikalisch engagiert hat.
Und der hat mit einer Künstlerin namens Sabrina Zedlur einen Song gemacht,
der den Titel hat, Nur mir und das im Jahr 1997 und für diesen Song hat er eine
zweisekündige Sequenz aus einem Schlagzeugzeug,
Teil aus dem Kraftwerk-Track. Diejenigen von euch, die vor 50 Jahren zur Schule
gegangen sind, erinnern sich, Kraftwerk, die mit der Autobahn.
Tanzmusik ohne zu tanzen aufführen und so. Stehen immer alle nur stocksteif.
Wahrscheinlich aus Hannover.
Stehen immer so steif auf der Bühne, machen herausragende, generationenprägende elektronische Musik.
Kraftwerk-Track, Metall auf Metall. Von 1977, 50 Jahre her.
Also 20 Jahre lang haben die mit ihrem Track die Ruhe, dann kommt Moses Pelham daher,
nimmt zwei Sekunden daraus und verhunzt die in einem Track mit Sabrina Sedlur
und Kraftwerk-Mitgründer Ralf Hütter sagt, da geht's so nicht und klagt.
Und damit, das war der Aufschlag zur längsten urheberrechtlichen Auseinandersetzung
in der Geschichte der Bundesrepublik Deutschland,
die durch zahlreiche Instanzen Entscheidungen ging.
Und diese Saga kam am 14.
April 2026 vor dem Europäischen Gerichtshof in der Rechtssache C-59-23 zu einem Ende,
Finale, Höhepunkt,
Klimax, aus Schlussakkord, will man sagen. Und zwar...
Haben gewonnen. Moses Pelham, sein Partner Martin Haas und Sabrina Sedlur.
Und das ist Rechtsgeschichte, weil damit jetzt der Begriff Pastiche erstmals
verbindlich definiert ist.
Und ein Pastiche ist, wenn ein Werk an ein Bestehendes erinnert,
dabei aber erkennbare Unterschiede aufweist und einen künstlerischen Dialog mit dem Original führt,
dieser kann als Hommage, Stilnachahmung oder kreative Auseinandersetzung erscheinen
oder zum Beispiel indem Moses Pelham zwei Sekunden Schlagzeug aus dem Grafik-Trick nimmt.
Und damit ist Sampling eine Praxis, die im Hip-Hop, kennst du Hip-Hop, Tim?
Oder das kennst du gar nicht mehr? Das war nicht deine Zeit,
wo man Tracks nimmt und einzelne Teile
davon, zum Beispiel zwei Sekunden Schlagzeug-Solo, hätte ich verstanden.
Und damit ist das als zulässige künstlerische Praxis anerkannt.
Das ist super. Also ich meine mit Hip-Hop hab ich es jetzt nicht so,
aber im Dijon ist natürlich geklaut worden wie nix Gutes und da ist das ja auch
ein ganz elementares Ding.
Den Begriff Pastis kannte ich übrigens noch nicht. Ist übrigens ein...
Doch, der wurde ja schon öfter verwendet.
Ein Kofferwort ist das richtig sehr.
Ich kenn nur Panaché, das Bier mit Limo in Frankreich.
Das hab ich ungefähr so in dem Alltag 1997 gelernt. wenn ich ehrlich sein soll.
Also französisch heißt es Nachahmung,
und Pasticcio auf Italienisch heißt Pastete.
Das wiederum auf französisch Pat heißt.
Jetzt haben wir da eine Schleife in unserer Argumentation. Okay, gut.
Auf jeden Fall Metall auf Metall heißt ja der Song von Kraftwerk,
der von Moses Pederm geplündert wurde.
Zwei Sekunden können wir einspielen.
Zwei Sekunden. Aber welche zwei Sekunden? Wenn wir jetzt genau die gleichen
nehmen, dann ist das klar, für andere zwei Sekunden müssen wir uns dann haben.
Dann haben wir die nächsten 30 Jahre zu tun.
Da haben wir richtig hier, aber...
Es gilt nicht jede Übernahme automatisch als Pastille, sondern ein erkennbarer
künstlerischer Bezug ist erforderlich.
Das war glaube ich auch das, worüber die sich 30 Jahre den Kopf zerbrochen haben,
um an Moses Pelham einen erkennbaren künstlerischen Bezug.
Naja, ich meine, wenn er irgendwie Stefan Raab da eine Kerbe gegeben hat.
Das war ein Kunstwerk. Ja, das ist so ein Kunstwerk.
Das wäre von der Kunstfreiheit gedeckt gewesen. Nee, da hat er glaube ich auch
einen für, da hat er damals einen für gekriegt, auch Jahre später.
Aber da reagiert der Stefan Raab empfindlich, würde ich aber auch.
Da bin ich auch ganz ehrlich, wenn mir jemand die Nase bricht,
wäre ich auch, da würde ich keinen Spaß mehr verstehen.
Haben die sich jetzt so geboxt oder war das wieder irgendeine Fernsehnummer?
Der tritt doch immer so Schlag den Raab mäßig gegen alle an oder sowas?
Der hat Schlag den Raab.
War das nicht in dem Raab?
Nee, das war Schlag den Raab, bevor er Schlag den Raab war.
Also ist überhaupt erst auf die Idee gekommen? Kreative Eingabe war das.
Jetzt kann der Moses Bellem bei Schlag den Raab die ganze Kohle einklagen. Wer hat's erfunden?
Und dann sagt Stefan Raab, nee, das war ein Pastiche.
Ich mach dir gleich Pastiche.
Ich weiß auch nicht genau, warum der den gehauen hat. Ist mir eigentlich auch egal.
Kann man ja auch kurz mal rausfinden hier.
Nein, wir verurteilen jede Gewalt.
Genauso wie als irgendein anderer Rapper hat ja dem Olli Pochhammer auf die Fresse gehauen.
Im Jahr 97 brach Moses Pellem dem Entertainer Stefan Raab bei der Echo-Verleihung
mit einem Kopfstoß das Nasenbein, nachdem Raab ihn in seiner Sendung wie Vasion
wiederholt verspottet hatte.
Das ist auch ein bisschen uncool, oder?
Natürlich, Moses Pelham ist eine komplette, ich sag jetzt nichts,
bevor ich nachher einen auf die Fresse kriege oder 30 Jahre Rechtsstreit mit
dem führen muss, aber der ist natürlich.
Der wurde zu 10.000 D-Mark Schmerzensgeld und 40.000 D-Mark Bußgeld verurteilt.
Ja, schlag den Raab. Ich meine, es ist nachher eine Millionenidee geworden.
Die haben sich ja auch alle echt nicht unter Kontrolle. Pelham setzt nach dem
Urteil eine Prügel-Premier aus, was zu einem befristeten Boykott seiner Musik
durch die Medien führt. Oh Mann, ey.
Vielleicht war das jetzt doch nicht so eine gute Nachricht. Egal.
Ich wollte gerade sagen.
War mir mal eine geile Nachricht.
Dann gab es ja noch irgendwie einen, aber ab und zu kriegen die mal einen auf
die ab und zu kriegst du mal also ab und zu gerätst du halt an den Falschen
mit deinem Witz und dann ja.
Verstehen die ja kriegst du Respekt.
Respekt Nasenbruch,
nein ja es ist natürlich ein,
lässt, spricht ja Bände über den Charakter und Ausdrucksfähigkeit von Moses
Pelham dass er mit seinem Kopf nichts Besseres anzufangen, weil es Stefan Raab die Nase zu bringen.
Ich finde auf jeden Fall, Kraftwerk muss ich ein bisschen zurücknehmen.
Also jetzt wegen zwei Sekunden da irgendwie so ein Hackback zu machen, echt.
Die hätten natürlich...
Als ob die irgendwas zu verlieren haben.
Also mal ehrlich.
Ich fand das, also ja, ich fand's...
Das nimmt sich aber gerade zu wichtig.
Ich fand's auch schwierig. Andererseits, wenn jetzt irgendwie Moses Pelham zwei
Sekunden von mir in seinem Lied hätte, wäre ich... Ich würde wahrscheinlich
einfach hingehen und denen die Nase brechen.
So, weißt du?
Einfache Lösung. Komplexe soziale Probleme.
Klären wir hier Frankfurt. Boom.
So, los, weiter hier, Termine.
Es gibt Termine, ja. Und zwar vom 22. bis 25.
Mai findet in München, im Münchner Chaos Computer Club, das Aktivsymposium München statt.
Unter dem Motto alternativlose Sicherheitsmaßnahme. Link gibt es in den Shownotes.
Da gibt es ein CFP, könnt ihr was einreichen.
Und das ist in München.
Dann springen wir vom Mai in den Juni und da findet in Berlin am 13.
Juni die Demonstration Sicherheit ohne Überwachung statt.
Also eine große Demo gegen das Sicherheitspaket 2.0, also in dem sich all diese
Sachen wiederfinden, KI-Überwachung.
Parlandtier, Legalisierung und sonstiges, über die wir hier in dieser Sendung
und in vielen anderen gesprochen haben.
Das ist ein Netzwerk von Personen und Organisationen der Zivilgesellschaft.
Die Demo findet statt in Berlin-Friedrichshain.
Treffpunkt ist an der Warschauer Brücke, 14 Uhr, Link in den Shownotes.
Dann könnt ihr noch ein bisschen in Berlin bleiben und mit dem ICE rüberfahren vom 26. bis 28.
Juni ist nämlich Hack an der Ruhr in Unna.
Auch da, Link in den Shownotes, auch da gibt es jetzt schon den CFP-System.
In Unna?
Unna.
Auf der Webseite steht Burghusen. Ist die in Unna?
Ich dachte, weil es von der Unn-Hackbar ist. Nein, es ist in Dortmund.
Tatsächlich, Burghusen in Dortmund.
Okay. Burghusen, ist das ein Ist das eine Burg?
Oder ist das ein Ah, okay.
Klingt so ein bisschen wie Das.
Ist noch was anderes. Ich weiß nicht, was Burghusen ist. Burghusen ist eigentlich im Schwarzwald.
Nein.
Doch.
Verband christlicher Pfadfinderinnen Westfalen. Da ist Burghusen.
Und das ist hier so eine Jugendherberge mit Zeltplatz.
Ja, sehr hübsch auch. Sehr romantisch.
Von außen, ja. Von außen sieht er gut aus.
Ja, von außen. Du könntest nur von außen betrachten.
Von innen.
Beurteilen.
Ja, obwohl hier, da gibt es einen urigen Gewölbekeller für die besonderen Anlässe.
Aha. Oh, klingt nach schwieriger Akustik. Also Podcast würde ich woanders machen.
Ja, also für die Akustik auf jeden Fall eher auf den Zeltplatz gehen, als in Gewölbekeller.
Eine Übernachtung.
Ist auf jeden Fall offiziell in Dortmund, nicht in Una. Also nicht,
dass ihr euch da verfahrt. So, was haben wir noch?
Da kostet die Nacht 640 Euro. Was ist das denn? Wahrscheinlich für einen kompletten Fahrtfinderverband.
Für eine Hackveranstaltung ganz schön.
Ja, aber warum soll man nicht das Geld ausgeben, solange das noch erklärt ist?
Ja, ich glaube auf der Veranstaltung zahlt man da nicht so viel.
Ich würde vermuten, dass das eher für eine komplette Schulklasse ist oder so.
Okay, es gibt auf jeden Fall noch einen Termin im September.
Im September ist das? Nee, die, äh, das ist ja jetzt im, ah, ah ja, okay. Genau,
vom 4. bis 6. September, Inselchaos. Inselchaos ist, glaube ich, auf Rügen.
Ein paar hundert Leute, da gibt es auch einen CFP, der CFP geht noch bis zum 1.
Juli. Das Inselchaos ist jetzt die zweite Iteration.
Event, das Kunst, Hacking, Musik und Austausch verbindet auf der wunderschönen Insel Rügen.
Rügen klingt immer so streng. Ich muss da immer dran denken,
dass man gerügt wird. Weißt du?
Das hat das, aber das ist da nicht. Bei denen ist nämlich Workshops, Talks und Happiness.
Da wird überhaupt nicht gerügt.
Da wird überhaupt nicht gerügt. Es sei denn, ihr benehmt euch nicht.
Und Rügen ist Mecklenburg-Vorpommern. Hätte ich auch nicht gewusst. Was?
Was sollen das sonst sein?
Das eigenes Bundesland, Rügen. Staat. Freistaat, Rügen.
Ja, das ist Megpom.
Du bist doch Seemann. Hast du schon mal Rügen umrundet?
Ich hab Rügen noch nicht umrügt.
Dann bietet das Inselchaos,
eine wunderbare Gelegenheit Im September segelst du ja wahrscheinlich an,
du segelst ja nur bei Schlechtwetter, Winter und so weiter, dann kannst du da
beim Inselchaos vorbei.
Das ist gar nicht so einfach, das ist in der Nähe von Bergen auf Rügen und das
sind Kilometer bis zum Wasser.
Ja, dann musst du halt eine Badehose.
Zu Hause lassen.
Da gibt es einen Baumwipfelpfad in Bergen auf Rügen.
Na dann.
Der ist mir zu hoch, da kriege ich Höhenangst.
Und Prora ist auch auf Rügen.
Dann ist Binz auch auf Rügen. Kennst du Ostsebat Binz? Du bist in der Nähe von Prora.
Ja, ich bin also so, ich bin damit vertraut.
Ich war da jetzt noch nicht so oft, aber das gibt's alles da.
Ja, das ist wirklich eine schöne Insel. Ich war da auch schon mal.
Und muss man auch, kommt man auch irgendwie, haben die eine Brücke oder so, die da hinführt?
Irgendwie glaube ich, man kommt da hin ohne mit der Fähre.
Ohne nass zu werden.
Man kommt da wunderbar mit dem Zuck hin.
Da kannst du da einfach strahlend, fährst du über die Brücke rüber und bist du da.
Also.
Ganz einfach.
Müsst du da noch nicht mal schwimmen. Was soll jetzt noch dagegen sprechen?
So. Kandocke, vielen Dank fürs Kommen und Berichten. Klagen und Beklagen.
Wie viele Klagen hast du eigentlich gerade offen?
Es war eine Premiere, aber ich glaube nach dem ersten Mal wird es leichter.
Dann kommt man einfach so ein bisschen in den Flow. Und du warst unter anderem
Deswegen so ruhig, weil du auf Frag den Staat die Anfrage gestellt hast,
dienstliche Signal-Kommunikation der Bundestagspräsidentin oder hatte das schon
jemand anders gestellt?
Das haben wir jetzt hier zack gemacht.
Antrag nach dem Informationsfreiheitsgesetz. Guten Tag, bitte senden Sie mir folgendes zu.
Via Signal-Messenger an die Bundestagspräsidentin Julia Klöckner gerichtete
Phishing-Nachrichten.
Ach schön, da freuen wir uns drauf. Da bin ich mal gespannt.
Ich glaube, das wirst du einklagen müssen.
Öffentliche Sicherheit, das geht nicht, ja.
Wir können ja jetzt nicht die Signal-Pin von Julia klicken.
Ach nee, das Konto ist ja weg.
Stimmt. Oh je. Naja.
Genau, sie haben leider keinen Zugriff mehr. Wir dauern Ihnen mit,
einzuwissen, dass Frau Klöckner keinen Zugriff mehr auf ihren Signal-Account hat.
So. Damit kommen wir zum Ende, Tim.
Damit kommen wir zum Ende, genau. Aber, Fun Fact, das ist nicht die letzte Sendung.
Wir kommen wieder. Keine Frage.
Ja, und die Sendung mit,
die andere Gastperson, die wir haben wollen, wird auch noch kommen.
Das kriegen wir schon hin.
Ich versuche die ganze Zeit auf Signal zu erreichen, aber die antwortet immer mit vier Zahlen.
Nein, es ist einfach nur Quatsch. Okay.
Ich hab auch noch ein Funfact hier zu Oliver Kalkofe.
Ich kann nicht mehr auf mit den Funfacts.
Ja, genau. Anfang 93 wurde Kalkofe von Seiten der rechtsextremen Szene wegen
Funksverhetzung angezeigt.
Grund hierfür war das Lied Zehn kleine Glatzenköp unter dem Namen der Kunstfigur
Onkel Hotte, was damals der totale Hammer war, super, welches sich eindeutig
gegen die rechtsextremistischen Umtriebe zur damaligen Zeit wendet.
Auch grobenbezogener Hass, das können die natürlich nicht.
Das Verfahren wurde nach kurzer Zeit wieder eingestellt und das Lied nebst dem
Märchen vom kleinen Skinhead auf CD veröffentlicht.
Der Reinerlös kam einer antifaschistischen Vereinigung zugute.
Onkel Hotze ganz großartig und auch der kleine Tierfreund von Geschmeyer.
Ich kann euch nur sehr empfehlen, beschäftigt euch mal mit Frühstücksradios.
Das ist wirklich grandios.
Das war es jetzt von uns. Wir sagen tschüss, bis bald.
Ciao, ciao.